Here we go.
Five,
four,
three,
two,
one.
First of all,
how many people get your name wrong
when they try to pronounce it?
Well,
so many people,
I don't even care anymore.
I just had it where it comes
out and cause I live in,
it's a funny name where I come from,
right from England who
grown up was a funny name,
but in Mexico is even stranger names.
So I just normally make it Ian,
I my second name Grillo,
which in Spanish is glio.
Right.
So everyone,
I messed that up too.
If they see it spelled yes.
A microphone about a fist from your face.
Right.
There we go.
Um,
Yo on,
I don't think I've ever
heard that name before.
Does enact a call young referred?
Was he in?
He's in fantastic four.
Oh really?
He's the stretchy guy.
Oh,
no shit.
In fantastic four.
So yeah,
he kind of,
he's made that name a little bit more,
a little bit more acceptable.
Um,
how did you wind up living in Mexico City?
So I came to Mexico or went to
Mexico and the year 2000 and uh,
I'll kind of messed around
for a few years in the UK.
What did the game to journalism.
So I found one way to get into it was
to start working in a foreign country
rather than going to my local newspaper
and work and go to a foreign country and
start working.
And I had a romantic idea about
Latin America thinking I'd be like,
I saw the movie Salvador.
Ah,
you know,
Oliver Stone's movie from the 80s.
I kind of had a,
had a,
had a romantic idea about
running around with grillers,
um,
fighting military dictatorships.
So I arrived in Mexico
in 2000 and got a job at,
I had an English language newspaper.
How old were you?
27 when I first left the UK.
Yeah,
28 when I,
I messed around for a
bit in Mexico as well,
and then got the job when I was 28.
Mexico City is a wild place.
Yeah.
It's so packed.
It's,
it's hard to,
I've only been there
twice for a UFC events,
but every time I'm there
I'm just shaking my head.
Like I can't believe
how it's traffic works.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
18 years.
Nothing.
A lot of time in that traffic.
Nobody cares about red lights,
green lights,
they don't care.
It's stressful.
Everyone who wants to
cut you up all the time.
Yeah.
People shout at you a lot.
You'd have to get used to people
calling you like Ben Deco cerebral.
I tried different tactics,
not just try and relax and not get angry.
Did you know how to speak
Spanish before you went there?
Yeah,
so I spent one year in Spain
living in Spain before I went.
Now I spent a year in
the Middle East as well.
Um,
and uh,
but yeah,
I started off when I arrived
I spoke more to Spanish,
Spanish,
which is like all yet DLC on your deal.
And then I changed more to
like the Mexican Spanish,
which was like,
oh,
your way.
Keep us all away.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
So when did you start getting
into narco journalism?
So like I arrived to say with the
romantic idea about what I might cover in,
in,
uh,
in Mexico or Latin America and right
away realize all that idea of grillers in
military dictatorships that have gone.
That was the last century.
Mm.
Che Guevara,
all that stuff had gone.
But right away when I arrived,
my very first off,
first I back in the UK,
grew up around a lot of drugs in the UK.
So going back to the eighties,
I grew up a lot,
people taking drugs.
I had a few friends who died from heroin
overdoses back then for people I knew
died of heroin overdoses.
I had a sister who went to,
became a schizophrenia smoking a lot of,
a lot of went up.
She was,
became script schizophrenia.
Can their bill of drugs being
smoked around that time as well?
Was it pot?
Yeah,
back then it was a Moroccan hashish.
There's,
there,
there is a connection,
you know,
and we've been exploring
that a lot lately.
Um,
we,
we went into this,
uh,
marijuana debate between,
um,
uh,
Alex Borenstein and I'm Dr. Mike Hart
from Canada and we talked about it and I
know people that have had that happen to
them where they've had schizophrenia or
a psychotic breaks because of
just massive doses of marijuana.
And especially people that don't do it
or people that do it too much for too
long.
It does happen.
I had that debate.
That's one of the reasons
why it came to mind.
Uh,
I mean,
I don't know a lot of people smoke weed,
a lot of people.
It's fine.
Uh,
now when,
when my sister had a breakdown when she
was 18 and I was 16 at a time and when
that came out,
it turned out awesome.
My,
my,
my grandmother had an issue
with schizophrenia and I
think identity as a time
bomb waiting to go off or
if it was how much the,
the,
the hatch was involved in that.
There's other issues as well.
So I don't really know the science of it,
but Ben way going back.
So,
so I've been around a lot of drugs before.
Um,
so when I arrived in Mexico,
actually one of the first,
uh,
first arriving in Mexico,
I ended up hanging around with some,
some people and they were
smoking a lot of crack in Mexico.
It's one of some of
the first people I met.
Wow.
Um,
I was,
I went down to the beach,
like backpacking down to the beach
and these people were smoking,
smoking crack.
And I was like,
this is kind of strange.
I didn't know those people
smoking crack down here.
So when I got a job at the local newspaper
in English and I just started looking
at the crime thing,
one of the first deals I did was on the
issue of crack being sold locally and
how that linked to the cartels.
And then very soon does very,
very quick.
I just fell in right away.
Like I said,
all these things happen by accident.
I just fell into covering the crime
beat and this has gone back to 2001.
So 2001,
it was the same year that chapel
was man escaped from prison.
Uh,
then I was calling a lot then to
a great journeys from twiner has,
who's plan con ls.
You're a real legend from Tijuana
who survived the shooting by it,
by cartels and you know,
phoning him up all the time.
Just getting him and had given
me information can be tips.
And that is how it
really started with that.
And our big store,
I did it back in those days was a,
the court marshal if some
generals for drug trafficking.
And that was really where it began.
That'd been generals for drug traffic.
How much of an issue is that?
Uh,
I mean,
corruption must be
unbelievably ramping.
So I mean,
corruption even isn't
necessarily enough word for it.
Sometimes I could state capture,
I'm gonna say this is the real beginning
and it has been a whole crazy 18 years
of covering this stuff means
this is the very beginning about,
and I've seen a whole lot of,
for a crazy stuff in that time,
but like,
just to get a sense of how bad the
corruption is or what it really means and
the,
on the ground level,
they're like,
there's a policemen.
Let you interview policemen,
you get to know the
policemen in a certain town,
certain city.
Um,
and it's hard to know in a hat or military
guys are politicians and you want to
believe these are good people.
You want to believe there's good policemen
out there who really want to stop
crime.
So there was one policeman,
his nickname was Tice at Dyson,
like Mike Tyson.
His nickname was Tyson because
he was a world built bloke,
well built guy and uh,
he was friendly with depressed
gut from Mitchell can friendly,
would depress.
Um,
and then it came out that he was actually
a drug cartel member ranking member in
a drug cartel and he actually confessed,
they,
they used to have a
thing where the police,
the federal police,
when they got him,
got him to confess on
camera and he confessed.
Not only was he turning a blind eye,
not only was he carrying out murders,
he was training the young kids
how to the capitate people,
how to cut people up.
And it was expanding in graphic
detail how he like in a,
how they managed to cut limbs off.
Halle gets young people train the cut
limbs off to get them to lose their fear.
So that's the level of corruption that
could be a policeman you're dealing with
and that's really who they are.
Um,
so that's one of the craziest things
about a corruption down there.
Did you have any hazards
Tinsey in getting involved in
narco journalism knowingness?
I mean I would imagine that's
one of the most dangerous
avenues to pursue in journalism.
So this was little by little,
I got involved in cover knee,
so like,
like going back to 2000
and this hadn't happened,
this war hadn't happened.
It was still like a crime
issue at that moment.
So I began to cover these things.
And then around 2004 I got a job for
the Houston chronicle out of Houston,
Texas.
I was covering,
I was a string of covering Mexico for
them and I flew up to a lot to Nuevo
Laredo and there was a
turf war beginning there,
which is really the
beginning of the drug war,
which is toward Mexico.
Part began on the border with Texas
in this city called Nuevo Laredo.
Over the bridge from Laredo,
Texas back in 2004.
So there was a lot of interest
from the Texas newspapers,
what was going on as a whole
bunch of bodies piling up there.
But again,
it's going back to these days and
this is kind of innocent looking back,
innocent,
looking at myself then an innocent
looking at what Mexico is like.
Then they would simply say,
go to the place I draw up the Monterey,
rent a car and just drive the car to
Norbury either with bus by myself.
And now people just don't do that.
This is too much crazy stuff going on.
But back then it was still
light or you can just do that.
So there was,
you see crazy stuff.
Like what kind of crazy stuff?
I mean,
now you can get stopped by an
armed group driving on those roads.
He could,
you could just drive along and it could
be a group of guys with guns could stop
the car,
get someone out,
takes take your way.
I mean,
there's a whole people a
lot more careful about,
you know,
where you are now.
Now when,
um,
when you move around the roads,
you can be very careful how you
move and how you plan this stuff.
You don't just wander by yourself.
Dry ran these places.
So,
so back then when this
was happening and um,
there was,
uh,
this body's turning up and was
trying to figure out why and,
and I,
uh,
there was one guy I interviewed who
was a head of chamber of Commerce.
Um,
and uh,
talk to me,
no,
very interesting guy.
About a couple of weeks later,
he became the chief of police for
the city and they asked him and said,
are you scared?
Um,
you know,
you scared about being killed?
He said,
no,
I'm not scared.
It's under the corrupt
people who get killed.
And he was shot dead six hours
after he gave that statement,
they shot him dead.
And that was one of the real markers.
If something really strange
is going on in Mexico,
something is like going
to erupt in Mexico.
Uh,
and then from there it kind of
just escalated and escalated and,
um,
started working by the other media,
Time magazine,
New York Times different people.
Enough to what I said,
I can't do the,
I can't just write new stories about this.
I've got to write books about this
because this stuff is big and it's
complicated.
It must be immensely complicated
for the people that live there.
It seems like there's no escape.
I mean,
if
you can't turn to the police,
the police are the cartel.
There's the cartel,
the police,
all the politicians,
most likely if they're alive,
have to be compromised.
Yeah.
I mean,
there's been some varied,
very desperate people and I mean,
there's been some bird has been
some inspirational people as well.
Fight in this.
There's been heroes.
There are heroes.
Um,
just to get more of a sense of what
that means on the ground as well.
Uh,
I,
and I,
and some of the things you see,
uh,
you know,
some of the things that stay
with me in Africa for a while,
it was quite romantic covering this.
It was like,
wow,
I'm covering,
I'm going to these
places where chapel goes,
man is from,
you know what?
I've got up to the village
of me's mother meets family.
I'm writing about these,
these crazy people,
but then you start seeing that
the human pain in all of this.
Um,
one of many stories that stick
with me was a mother in Monta Ray,
a school teacher,
you know when you have
arm guys moving around,
they're also like,
uh,
really effecting the civil population,
had attacking the civil population.
And one mother,
um,
she was in our home with our
two children in Monterrey and a,
it was like in the night,
just chilling in their house and in the
door broke down and about 15 guys in
bulletproof jackets or came in long
arms just taking stuff from the house.
How'd the family and I pinned him
down and they said to the mother,
which of your children as the oldest?
And she was like,
didn't know how to apply.
I mean,
which of your children?
The oldest,
how do I grow?
How do I reply to that?
She just couldn't speak.
And the eldest,
Satya Tucson's one 18,
one 15,
the 18 year old was a
philosophy student and he said,
um,
I'm on the oldest.
So like a Yukon with
us and took them away.
The next day she got a phone call saying,
oh,
can we got your sign?
Give us this amount of money.
We'll give them back.
So she went round to like
relatives just got the money.
She wanted to get the money right away.
She turned up with the money,
gave some money,
and then they just cut off the calls
and she hadn't heard from him since.
And I,
I said miss seeing her face,
the devastation and the page that I,
you know,
just couldn't,
couldn't go on with life after
that and just not knowing,
not having the closure.
And I met her when I went to report
on one of the worst atrocities,
which was 49 borders,
who'd all been decapitated or had their
hands and feet cut off and all been
dumped on a road and they
would take them to the Morgan.
Monta Ryan arrived in the morgue.
I was inside.
The more to smelling the smell of the
dead bodies is kind of weird smell you get
from like decaying flesh,
kind of a sweet smell you get from when
you're around those places where you can
smell that the body is the k and I was
inside the Morgan a came out is outside
the morgue and she was trying to see if,
if her son might be among those people,
among those bodies.
Wow.
But you know,
it's,
it's so insane that this is right next
door to America and there's so little
effort put on doing something about it,
including doing something to mitigate
the influence of illegal drugs by making
drugs legal.
I mean,
that would be one gigantic step.
You're,
you're not going to stop
people from doing drugs.
I mean,
this is an illogical,
ridiculous approach.
I don't think people should
do most of those drugs,
but when you make drugs illegal,
only criminals are going
to sell those drugs.
And this is exactly what you
have right next door to American.
It's just unbelievably insane
that there's this amount of crime.
A drive away from San Antonio.
Oh
yeah.
And talking about that issue of the
money and the economics of days.
So I mean,
you look at cocaine,
so you could say you've got the,
there was four main drugs,
now it's,
you've got fentanyl coming in as well,
and the,
and the cartels and making fentanyl,
they're making it,
making it yet.
And I made it and making
it bring in precursors,
making it as a lab.
One lab,
I was in Nogales,
uh,
about a year and a half ago,
they passed a lab in
Nogales rotten the border.
They'll make them have the lab they're
making the finet Fenton in and bring up
eh,
but as well as that you've got
out of the four main drugs,
historically a marijuana,
uh,
heroin,
cocaine and crystal meth.
And this goes back a hundred years.
Like so Sinhala,
which is the cradle of
Mexican drug trafficking.
It's in the low,
is a bit like Sicily as to the Mafia and
likes in an arrest and a Mexican drug
cartels where it began.
And it began right to go back to 1914 you
had in the u s to Harrison's narcotics
tax act when they made a,
they restricted opium and
cocaine in the United States.
And from 1915,
they began a cross border trade
from Mexico to the United States.
So that's when it started
all the way back then.
So over a hundred years ago,
some of the very first people doing it,
we're actually Chinese Mexicans.
They were Chinese immigrants
that arrive in Mexico.
They began doing this,
they bought opium,
um,
from,
from China planted in,
in Mexico.
And some of the first people
receiving it with Chinese Americans.
Some of these very early cases,
a case from 1916 investigated his
documents about this case where there was
Chinese Mexicans trafficking to
Chinese Americans here in California.
And at that time there
was a governor of Baja,
California involved.
Um,
right back then.
What is the solution?
Is there any solutions to this?
Well,
I mean,
I get,
you know,
I think a lot of people covering this,
you get very weary.
You want to see solutions.
Um,
you want to find solutions and you want
to come with that optimism of finding
solutions and you want to
justify why you're doing this.
What you're doing is for not just to tell
the stories but to look for solutions
to this.
Um,
and it,
it gets worried about that.
There's three areas.
I believe that our traditions first,
I do agree with you on the
idea of drug policy reform.
Again,
it is tough uphill battle.
I mean going back to 2012
I wrote editorials about,
you know,
one of the reasons you should legalize
marijuana is because of the marijuana
come from Mexico,
which goes to cartels,
which pays killers,
which pays for corruption.
But at the same time,
marijuana,
a lot of,
you know,
love is legalized in the United
States and the violence has,
she just got worse in Mexico.
So you've also got the issue of heroin,
uh,
cocaine,
crystal Meth,
fentanyl,
and you've got the cartels are
going to bunch of other rackets now.
They're still crude oil,
which is a big deal.
They still billions of dollars worth
of crude oil criminals down there from
pipelines can tap into
a pipeline or something.
Yeah.
You kind of pipeline you have,
you'd normally put in two taps.
You drill two holes in the pipeline,
you drill a hole to put,
to take the oil out,
you'd drill a hole to put water
in to try and keep it equal.
Uh,
the pressure,
the same Dev you saw as a
crazy video recently of a,
in a,
in a small town in
Mexico where a bunch of,
there was a tap open of really,
really bad tap,
the origins spraying out and a bunch of
people were lining up just to pick up
the oil from the pipeline
and exploded and just,
it was just like crazy death toll.
Yeah.
I did see that from,
from,
from Nada,
but a bad way that I do believe in,
in a,
in drug policy reform,
we have to talk about,
this has to be on a table.
I mean,
Americans,
there's,
you know,
no one knows really what
American spend on drugs,
but as the survey are where you can
find on line if you just tap and what do
Americans spend on illegal drugs?
And it is an estimate
of $100 billion a year.
So,
you know,
that amount of money I've been,
that's an estimate.
I mean,
it could be right.
You know,
it's hard to know how
it's a very round number,
but like $100 billion a year.
Now,
if you think about that pumping
into these cartels year after year,
I mean,
decades.
You know how much of that,
if it's 30 billion of that guide
down in Mexico in over 10 years,
300 billion over 30 years,
close to a trillion dollars,
that really creates this,
this monster,
but know a secondary.
So I'm not believe in drug policy reform.
I mean,
I don't know how,
I mean Rehab,
they want to needs it because
heroin addicts by lot of heroin.
So every one you save from that you can,
uh,
you know,
you can stop a lot of heroin
and a lot of that money.
What does money goes to these
people who are doing this stuff.
But a second area I
believe is his social work.
Uh,
in the neighborhoods.
like I've talked to,
I've done a lot of interviews with
particularly with the assassins,
with the killers in cartels in
Mexico and also around Latin America.
I've been traveling around Jamaica,
Brazil,
Central America,
Colombia,
talking to a lot of
the killers especially.
And when I sit down with them,
I try and get their life story.
Like how did they first get into this
because you're not born doing this stuff.
And often,
I mean,
in some cases that is
the different profiles.
There's some of them,
uh,
in noticed one,
one guy,
this is done in Honduras,
which is also crazy situation,
was a guy there.
I actually met him before I'd met him
when I was doing some reporting down there
back in 2015.
And he was driving for us and he was
also carrying a gun to help protect us as
with the journeys to that I had had,
had been hit before.
We've been actually shot before.
And,
uh,
then I met him again afterwards
and gone to tell his story,
which is kind of typical
of a lot of these guys.
And he described how he been abandoned
as a kid by his parents and had this real
hate that he had with the world.
Like,
and I just fucked a world.
Um,
and he described the first time
that he carried out murders.
Um,
and it,
this is us though.
I'm an he carried out.
They already doc,
he documented all these hits he'd done
and to capitations he'd done in his kind
of crazy stuff.
But the first time a cat it,
a murder was probably the,
the,
the freakiest when he was
I think 14 and they got a,
a family,
they went into a house,
I couldn't a lot.
They've got family and
they butchered a family.
And he described when he described
that and then described later on,
you know,
how he became a higher killer.
And the thing about him,
like some of these people you
think they're psychopaths,
they just,
they really don't care.
But some of them really do have
these conflicts inside the heart.
I think he was someone or a list of
back to that interview and he had,
and it's hard to,
to balance that someone who does evil
but also has it been a victim as well,
a victim and the victimizer.
And you feel that pain since,
since then he himself been been murdered.
Um,
but uh,
yeah,
he's uh,
who's,
you know one,
so how you get social work to reach
people from a very young age because often
they are recruited into
organized crime when they're 12,
13 years old.
So he butchered his family when was 14
when it was his stealing money from them.
So the story would,
that was,
he said that he was hanging around with
these basically street kids and one of
the other kids said,
I know where there's
some money in a house,
we can get some money in a house.
So they went in there and
killed his family and it
turned out there was no money
there.
And the reason the other kid had said
go there was because he'd actually been
living with his family and he
said they'd been abusive to him.
So he wanted to like Rivett
have revenge on his family.
Well what was so really sick of that is
to when he was describing it was they
had this family and they would to
stop them defending themselves.
They would like take them one by one,
like pin him in a,
in a room and take them one by one.
I'd take them out,
butchered them how the other ones
didn't really know what was going on and
think,
I mean the action itself,
but how like teenage kids
can think about that stuff.
And then later on when he
was talking about the uh,
decapitations he was talking about they
get contracts with the capitation inside
the quite like they say,
look,
we want this killing.
We wanted to to capitate a guy,
we want this doc,
we want to see video of
the guy being the cap tech.
We want that.
We want the guy to suffer.
And when he hacks the heads off,
dare sometimes still be a moment when
like when the life goes out of them and
when the body is still luck.
Twitching.
Lucky says they can still see like
was there's a bit like nerves.
It was like a chicken,
like a headless chicken.
There's a bit as a part when
he's still like twitching a bit,
even after day or you know,
they've lost a kind of seven there,
connections there.
Ooh.
Now when you're interviewing these people,
how nervous are you?
I mean this seems like if you're
putting all this stuff down,
you could implicate them in some crimes
and it seems like it would be very
convenient for them to
try to get rid of you.
So is,
there's a whole bunch of different
situations around interview.
So some labs,
I've interviewed people in prisons,
a lot of time in prisons.
Um,
you know,
this took me years to,
to get to a lot of these people.
First of all,
you know,
W it wasn't like,
uh,
um,
when I first started
doing this I was like,
you know,
how do I get,
how do I reach them and start going
around to drug rehab places and talking to
people in Drug Rehab?
I'm going into prisons and NCLR wireless.
I did a lot of interviews in and in one
prison I got to know a lot of prisoners
and the prisoners [inaudible] in a
Christian evangelical wing there and they
were going through this
weird Christian in.
I like Christina in a discovery of God
there and then through the street on the
street,
often light through content.
I mean we're old time through
contacts on the street.
Um,
and in Honduras,
a lot of great contacts with a friend
is a journalist who grew up in his
neighbors.
We'd,
all of these guys,
he just knows,
knows that his guys from growing up now.
Yeah,
there's different,
different things,
you know that have been bad situations.
I think anybody covering this
has had some bad situations.
Sometime people get angry,
people threatened them and so forth.
But a lot of the time when it's,
when you talk to people,
yeah.
And one thing that you
have to be very low Tom,
you have to be very stringent about
protecting the identity and really serious
about that because there's been cases
where various cases where other people
have interviewed killers and shown their
identity either through the [inaudible]
face or through like some dumb thing
being showed and they have been themselves
murdered in a butchered after these x
given these interviews or like other
things are happened,
they'd been threatened or something
to family or arrested or Sifo.
So you really got to
protect people's identities.
Okay.
In a way in terms of when they talk and
stuff and I didn't really feel nervous
when I need one of these people,
I probably feel more
nervous hit or come to you.
That's just 40 kids.
It's like all the other on a big show.
It's a different,
a different thing when
you're like talking to
first,
you know,
you start with easy questions,
like anything,
you start talking about how in
a how you know people are human,
they're human beings
and people have got it.
People are complicated and I haven't
just interviewed and I've also got drunk
with somebody people and
hung around with somebody.
People.
Um,
for times trying to get closer,
like,
uh,
you know,
spent time to try and understand
their world a bit more.
What's the most time you've
ever spent with these people?
Um,
in several days.
Several days.
Yeah.
Like a in I like I'm a
now CEDAM see him again,
hung out with in a hangout with them.
I in different places,
not all the time,
sometimes just,
you know,
sit down and do interviews and just leave.
Uh,
but it's,
it's,
it's a complicated world for them is
it's their normality knows if for them is
normal.
Uh,
it's,
it's what they've,
what they've lived,
what they've been through,
what's happening around them.
Um,
and this level of murder,
this happened a lot of parts of
Latin American now it's crazy.
But in these areas is in his,
what?
He talked to other people who
had just on the edge of this,
we'll have family members involved in
this and it's just they're living this,
I mean,
these are levels of violence and it's
interesting to compare historically these
levels of violence.
Um,
because you look at some of the
worst cities like San Pedro,
Sula on Doris Caracas
harm Sierra wireless,
and these are places which
have levels of violence,
which are like way worst
in medieval Europe,
a lot based in medieval Europe.
I mean,
look at the figures per hundred thousand
because some of them have over a
hundred,
a hundred thousand,
150,
100,000 and medieval Europe a lot.
These cities were like
20 per hundred thousand.
So they're way worse,
way worse in the wild west than like
now there are some place in the United
States,
the de la.
Oh.
And I did and I've done some research
recently in Baltimore Marin hand and I was
kind of,
it's interesting to compare that to
Latin America and that's a high level.
That's 40 by a hundred thousands
that's not as the same level,
but it's significant still
more than medieval Europe.
Yeah.
Wow.
Baltimore is worse than Medieval Europe.
Yeah.
I'm going to ask.
That gets,
you have to have to do some professors
then they weren't in a like you get like,
you know they might be,
they might say,
well Jerusalem in this
time or in a line I like,
you've got to try and it's hard to note
that it really dig down exact club net.
There was outbreaks of violence
and killing in certain places,
but the overall average
of all average year,
that's a significant leap.
100% leap ea.
Absolutely.
Baltimore.
What about South side of Chicago?
It's not that,
I mean like the level I think in Chicago
comes out around 20 or something,
so it's not now the Emerg
that of the whole city.
Now these again,
and one of the things about the violence
in the United States compared to Latin
America in Baltimore is,
is,
is significant bit of fairly what the
city of Baltimore is a fairly small place
where they're talking about.
So in Mexico you have entire states
that are like really violent or entire
countries in Latin America,
whereas in the u s it tends to be
neighborhoods which are violent.
Um,
so if you really focus on
the south side of Chicago,
it's probably similar levels to Baltimore.
Then,
you know,
it's a,
but if you look at the whole city,
you've got neighbors did a
pretty safe in Chicago as well.
Now,
through all of this time that
you spent down in Mexico,
have you seen it?
You've seen it escalate,
you've seen it get worse and worse.
Yeah.
So there was first this really big
escalation happening in 2008 was the first
big escalation where
it was a cause of that.
So you had,
there was a steady build
up there was happening.
Um,
and then in 2006,
do you had the president fully pickar
that on Claire to military crack down on
drug cartels.
And after that with those as big response
and things started really getting out
of hand,
we'd already seen violence
escalating before.
And in my idea,
my kind of theory behind this is that,
um,
you had in Mexico back
in the 20th century,
more of a top down,
um,
centralized government
controlling everything you had,
the Pri and power and they were basically,
they will have to coordinate
through corruption.
So back then they'd have the drug cartels
working for them and an interesting
story guy.
And back then,
the 19 day nine 70 store in a book
called drug lord by Terence Popper who
interviewed,
uh,
a drug trafficker in the
eighties when he got the,
his job is to ha have hit a plateau,
which is the head of a certain territory.
When he got the job,
he went with the state
police at the time and said,
I want to become the head of the plaza.
And they took him in and
tortured him for two days unlike,
and I beat the crap out of him,
put electric shocks on his nuts.
One of the big taught at Dmexco put
water laced with Chile in his nose.
Smell like one of these big,
so your whole face burns.
He's a like torture techniques they have.
And after two days of
torture him and said,
yeah,
well done,
you know,
you survived.
Well you've got the job.
So we know what it shows is that
the police had the upper hand,
the police control this.
They were like,
okay,
we control this racket and you know,
we can fuck around and
tortured and killed.
Rock rock was when we like,
uh,
you know,
in all up the presidency.
I mean,
there was a,
in that time,
Carlos Salinas became
president in [inaudible] 94,
his brother Raul Salinas,
there,
there's the Swiss investigators,
bank accounts and said he had
$500 million in bank accounts.
We say,
you know,
they,
they believed it was drug money.
So right up to the presidency,
this was was being run.
Ooh,
when makes a code change democracy.
So when I arrived in Mexico was
changing to democracy and it's like,
wow,
great democracy is going to happen.
Free markets going to happen.
You know,
we're in a good days
at a 21st century now.
But what happened was you'd look
to political control shifted.
So you had a bunch of different political
parties and they were fighting over
the drug trade.
And you know,
I was one time in regular echo when the
federal police had a shootout with the
municipal police.
They were fighting each other probably
because they work for different drug
cartels.
Wow.
So that's what started.
But then you had the techniques,
like the technique of beheading
wasn't really a big deal.
It was very,
very rarely used up until around 2006
and one of the first incidents was in
acapulco in 2006 in about June,
2006 now it might have been after
inspired by the al Qaeda car,
we in a video which was
shown him full of Mexican TV.
I remember when that came out,
when they'd decapitated the guy in Iraq
and they decapitate first
it was two policemen,
Eddie capitate.
Later that year in September,
2006 there was five heads,
they rolled onto a disco dance floor.
And then his thing just became,
just escalating,
just became this kind of light
using his terror public terror.
So 2006,
2008 was a big escalation and
then 2011 12 were like crazy.
And then it subsided a bit in a pub.
The violence got bit less public
and it was more like hidden,
like mass grave stuff.
Now the worst mass grave
has been discovered so far,
um,
was in Veracruz.
I've been to the side of it and it was
250 bodies were found in this mass grave
in one place and it was right
next to a housing estate.
And there's families who was,
so one of the saddest things was you sick.
You see their kid is bicycles
and basketball hoops and
stuff right next to this
and the field next to that,
they'd dub up 250 bodies and the smell
was like emanating to this housing
estate.
And he's looking at a Middle Clark,
the dream of becoming middle class.
That was the,
the kind of in this housing
state and right next to it,
this violence.
But when I say a lot of these stories
and having been the crazy stories,
but a lot of the weird thing is a lot
of Mexico lives in normality around this
is not what you,
this is not what you see every day.
This is why this happens.
But there's also just a normality
that could just be like,
you're outside here in la.
And normal people living normal
lives around this as well.
What is the response in Mexico?
Like what would it mean after they wanted
to have this military action against
the cartels?
Obviously that hasn't
really put a dent in it.
What,
what,
what's the,
the current thought process
behind dealing with this?
So there's been a,
there's a bunch of like citizen,
um,
protest movement various times,
during these recent years.
And wire them was,
it was a very interesting
gargled hobbyist,
Cecilia who is a poet and a
writer whose son was murdered.
And He,
when it first happened,
his son was murdered and he just came out,
sis the press where he's like an icon.
There's just like,
this is just,
you know,
Mexico's gone,
I can't,
I can't deal with,
is my son's being killed.
And then he began talking in very now and
then he went to the streets and people
coming out publicly,
um,
crying.
And it was one of the first
times there's a realization,
a lot of innocent people dying
with this and people come out.
And,
you know,
I went to some of these things.
People come out crying,
family members and she
actually a sense we,
we're victims here because there's a,
for a long time since it's
simply bad guys killing bad guys.
And that wasn't the case.
Now,
the current president,
Andres Manuel Lopez Obrador who just won
the election last year and he just took
power on December the first,
so he's got to mix things.
So one of them is this
idea of the war's over.
I'm going to create peace,
we can have forgiveness,
reconciliation and up is hard
to know what that really means.
And his second thing is we need to have,
um,
more of a unified state police.
So like what I described before about
you had local police fighting the federal
police.
So we've got to have,
so he's got this idea now,
the national guard,
which is a kind of hybrid between
military and police thing around,
and that's basically his,
his,
these kind of two thrusts he's in now.
He's only been in power
for a couple of months.
January was still a bad
month in terms of murders,
in terms of bodies.
Last year was more than
33,000 dead last year,
which is the size of Mexico,
the equivalent of the United
States having close to 100,000.
Now imagine what that would
mean in the United States.
If you had that many
people dying in a year,
a month,
the whole year in a year,
100,000.
Yeah.
Now,
when these people are,
when they're being
recruited by the cartels,
when the police officers
are being recruited,
the big issue must be will
they must be two issues,
right?
Safety.
Like if they don't join the cartel,
they probably get murdered.
And two,
the amount of money the cartel would
give them would be far more than the
government would give them to
be a legitimate police officer.
Yeah,
sure.
And that,
that's like a no.
Famously platinum blonde plateau,
plateau,
Poloma,
luck,
silver or led.
You want to have the silver of the bribe,
the lead of the bullet.
But,
but even beyond that for a long time,
a lot of these people
who joined the police,
uh,
like from the beginning,
they're in.
I,
I've taught,
I've got,
I've got on video,
uh,
met a video back in 2010 in
Sierra wireless of a bunch of,
uh,
of rappers just hang around
in the middle of all this.
And one of their friends were saying,
and they were talking and
these people were saying,
you know,
some of them been done for taking drugs,
have the board and they'd
been in gangs and stuff.
And one was like,
I want to be a policeman.
And he was like,
I want to be a policeman
and make some money,
you know,
basically through
corruptions that as I said,
it is like that is the
mentality of somebody.
People joining the police from early on.
Another guy,
Guy Open,
open a first book with his guy,
uh,
who,
who became policemen.
Um,
when he was 18,
he was basically a hard,
tough guy.
Pet American football from Durango,
became a policeman when he was 18 and
into police learn to torture and learned a
murder.
He said,
that's what I learned in a place.
And it just at 20 after two years,
just left the place and
went full time into crime.
And he's like,
so you know,
you've got a situation where you know,
it's not,
it's,
it's worse even as beyond
that they're the bad,
a lockable might imagine of corruption.
God.
So
all of this essentially is escalated
from the time you came to Mexico.
So when you came back to,
it sounds like you got in,
I mean,
if it was a story you got in
at almost the perfect time.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Horrible way.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean,
it's,
like,
you know,
you don't,
you don't do these things on purpose,
uh,
you know,
you don't think,
and if I look back 20 years ago,
I mean,
it's 18 years I've been in Mexico now,
I had grown up in Mexico and that,
in that sense,
I,
I've never looked back.
And I think that's it now in
terms of myself seeing this.
I mean,
it's,
I think for anybody it's paced,
painful.
I mean,
how you process that level of depth,
that level of murder,
level of suffering.
Uh,
it's,
uh,
it's horrible stuff to see and,
and,
and it's,
you could still have a lot of people,
um,
separated from that in our families.
People bring up children and,
you know,
you want to separate,
kids from that.
So off often,
like middle class kids in Mexico,
quite sheltered because families want to
shelter them as much as they can from,
from,
from that violence and just,
you know,
not let them see that side of things.
How much of that do you have
to deal with in Mexico City?
So Mexico City,
you know,
is about the same murder rate as Houston
to Mexico City is not supervised now.
It's still not super safe,
but it's not super Vinad.
So Mexico City is kind of,
and there are parts of Mexico,
which of which are fairly safe now the
state of Yucatan were meritorious is the
same murder level as Belgium.
So you've got oasis within Mexico where
you don't have this level of violence.
So Mexico City is it and is a great city.
Mexico City is a great city to live in
in many ways apart from the traffic and
the pollution and various things.
I mean,
there's a bunch of things that are,
and I know,
and I love all of Mexico
and I love all of,
you know,
Latin America.
I love even,
and even the bad places I still love.
I enjoy going to these places.
I enjoy meeting people there in a hangout,
in his areas.
There's a lot of good
things about him still.
But dealing with all the horrific
tragedies that you report about and
experience,
do you look for an escape route?
I mean,
are you,
are you looking to get
the fuck out of dodge?
Yeah.
How,
I mean,
um,
there's been different times where,
uh,
I,
I've thought,
you know,
I wanted,
I want to stop this now.
Uncover other things.
Yeah.
As a journalist.
And he's the other journalists doing
that as well as the journey is called
heads.
Who says,
give Eric Great Mexican
journalist who's just,
I just saw him at the,
uh,
tried of El Chapo,
over in New York and who's
been covering this for years.
One of the,
you know,
really great Mexican,
uh,
correspondence is covered,
the drug stuff.
And he was like,
he just said to me,
our butter,
I've got some stuff maybe I can give you.
This is the harm.
I'm [inaudible] this.
And the last thing,
I'm going to do,
Catherine trucks now and I,
we love,
we know we'll sit.
We'll see if that's true.
Um,
I think a lot of the time you get,
you know,
you get caught still doing this stuff.
You a piston when you,
when you've covered something,
people will want more,
people are interested as a,
and there's relevance to this.
Um,
I think some of the other
struggles beyond like the,
the danger in staff is simply,
I mean we'd journalism's in a bad way.
I love the media in a bad way.
Um,
and just simply getting know,
trying to be know I'm a free lance,
generous,
I love being a free last year and
they started loving independence.
I love being a write books and crackle
and write magazine stories and make
documentaries and do these things.
But like just in having
the economic base for that,
you know,
see she's degenerate and lots in
the time that I've been doing it.
Have you personally been targeted at all?
So there's a couple of situations or had,
um,
and I,
I mean,
first I,
when I know I'm going to have to give some
calm respect and,
uh,
condolences to so many colleagues,
Mexican colleagues who have
been murdered and been,
had been murdered,
threatened,
had to leave the country and various
things and they've had it bad.
Um,
including,
uh,
a friend,
a good friend,
a great colleague called Heavier
Bell Desk who was shot dead in 2017,
May,
2017 in cooler can a guy
I'd known since 2008,
um,
great guy,
got drunk with him in the Cantina,
very generous guy.
He wrote eight books,
a charismatic,
I mean,
you know,
really lovely guy who was shot
dead and many other stories.
So,
so I kind of don't want to give my own
compare Martin waste a lot of them in
many ways.
But yeah,
sure.
There's been times,
there's one time in a,
it was in the state called Mitchell
Afghan and this was 2014 and there was a
thing that happened there when a lot of
regular people rose up with guns against
the cartels.
They will known as outer defense as or
like self defense courts and they rose up
to fight the cartels and uh,
they,
you know,
a bunch of guys with guns.
It was kind of crazy situation
where there was his luck,
almost like a trench warfare
happen between cartels and
his self defense groups.
And then what happened was a lot of
regular gangsters started saying,
well,
we're self defense groups as well,
you know,
just coming up saying,
oh yeah,
we're self-defence equips,
you know,
those guys are out in
the street with guns,
you know,
we're just going to go out with our guns.
And so anyway,
I went down,
I drove down at the end of this have
been that I've been covering this right
through and it had been fairly
okay to do the self defense squads.
The outer defenses were pretty
easy going to work with,
but I drove down there to,
to Mitchell can,
um,
and I wanted to do some stuff on it and
I was going to meet a friend and our
journey,
she just backed out at the last minute.
I just went down there anyway and
arrived there and there was about 50 guys
arrived in this place near
the city called a passing Gan.
And there's about 50 guys who supposedly
as defense squad in a parking lot
getting ready to go on a mission to
try and take down this drug trafficker
called lap Dota.
And they were like,
they were sitting there.
It was a guy who like signing
them up for this kind of mission.
And there's a bunch of guys they were,
and they had very heavy weaponry.
They had AK 47 is that our 50,
is that grenade launchers,
um,
on there,
on the top of their guns
and beneath their guns.
They had like the
grenades strapped to them.
Lastly,
grenade on belts,
round them,
ammunition belt around them.
I'm not crazy.
Like,
you know,
like,
are you see the old
revolution we stopping?
I mean,
like real crazy,
like this Broadway stuff.
Uh,
and then,
uh,
I was talking to them,
I realized quickly this
would not self defense guys.
These would narco,
these were gangsters.
Them,
they,
you know,
they came out with it,
right?
They're like,
um,
you know,
I hadn't,
you been in the self defense movement?
Oh,
a couple of days now.
And they're like,
and then they had like guns
with like diamonds and hair fe,
um,
heifers down the boss.
Um,
and,
uh,
and I was getting were not okay.
When does,
it was kind of like,
um,
you know,
joking with his guys and take
some photographs of them.
So they were posing for photographs,
so it was sitting there with a,
like,
posing with the guns and
stuff in there and they said,
they said they have a,
the word Wedo is,
is like,
um,
it's not really white boys like Blondie,
you know,
it could mean like,
if,
if you're,
you're white in Mexico,
he often get called a wetter.
So like,
where it all,
um,
how much the prostitutes
costs in your country.
Like Gretchen did that you'd
have to go there and see it.
There's like a Weirdo or do you like take,
do you like taking meth?
Do you,
don't you know,
you like,
like taking meth?
Uh,
you know,
I'm,
I'm okay.
And I,
there was still like,
no,
you're kind of joking.
And this guy turned,
came up among them and he said,
uh,
the,
I tell the other guys and
the first of the big guy,
and he said that he was carrying a
big guy and he's got there woody,
massive head.
And he said to me,
a bit aggressive,
he just don't take my photo.
I was like,
yeah,
no problem.
I won't take your photo.
And then a guy came up and
said to the other guys,
say,
what are you doing this the Da guy here?
He said,
the agent among you
taking your photographs,
um,
you know,
what are you doing?
And I was like,
no,
I'm not,
I'm not even American.
I'm British.
And he said,
no,
you know,
this is a DEA guy.
My,
my,
my brother was arrested in Texas and the
Dea guy pretended to be a journalist,
you know,
some bullshit story.
And I said,
look,
I can,
you know,
I can show you my website.
So they've got the cell phone out and,
and look through it,
his cell phone and found out my website.
And the guy calmed down a bit and he said,
you know,
if you,
if I see you,
I'm going to put a bullet in your head,
I'm going to throw a grenade at you.
Is it?
He added.
So I left in,
I kind of tried to talk
about a left and uh,
yeah.
And,
and they went and then I didn't publish
the photographs I've still got and I
both to photo ops and one of the guys
sent me an email saying what happened to
photographs,
my emails and my website.
So I just ignored it.
And I think a lot of them got killed in
a big fight they had with the federal
police afterwards.
So that was one.
Um,
and it's been,
yeah,
it's been a few more.
So it's a lot of touch and go.
Yeah.
These situations.
The,
the federal police,
do they have a plan to try to
eradicate these moms or is it
a lot of lip service?
Like,
is it really possible to radically these
gangs or is it just one of those things
where they say they're going to do
something but they have to kind of protect
themselves?
You know,
there's,
there's been different different times.
I mean sometimes there's been the federal
police have done well done after a
particular guy or sometimes
with the Americans.
He no doubt been a,
um,
in our rest of very many
significant kingpins,
the problem is his word is the door doing
a deeper questions is that like when
you take down some of these kingpins,
you've always got other people who
will fight over their same territory.
So for example,
you take out Chapo Guzman and then you
get a fight among his sons and some odd
one of his lieutenants over it,
over the empire.
Now what's happened,
and one of the reasons the violence has
increased in Mexico is because they've
had this onslaught attacking
cartels over the years.
Then you end up with like the lieutenants
then taking over and then their
lieutenants taking over and then
their lieutenants taking over.
That's what happened in Chicago as well.
Or I spoke to a police officer in Chicago
and he said the violence escalated
afterwards.
Some big gang rests.
And once they had gotten,
some leaders have some gangs and
other people tried to fill the void.
Yeah,
exactly.
Exactly.
The sound.
So,
so then you get some of the
people who are in power now,
uh,
like very young,
very violent people and people who are
not as smart when those not as mature,
not calculated.
Yeah.
So,
so you to you and also
you end up with these,
the fragmented territory.
So you have people controlling
rather than having big cartel,
some leader who controls it and a half
the country you end up with these cartel
lethal allowed these gangs controlling
a part of the state now has one state
called good Arrow,
which you've seen this really light cartel
fragmentation and you've got maybe 12
different groups in this one state and
you get like a place where they're going
to one controls controller up along a
road and then in our group controls it
passing a certain point.
So there was some,
some friends went up there,
um,
seven journeys went up there and got held
up on this road up there 2017 as well.
And they got,
were in a car going like they're two
vehicles and about 200 guys blocked the
road and the leader of this group was
a guy I believe called [inaudible].
Um,
like again,
his name,
blondie,
polite and he's like maybe 23 years old,
like 200 guys there.
They said some of the kids,
I talked to,
one of the friends who was there and he
said some of these are kids who was the
youngest like 10 years old
among this mob of people.
And they,
they held him up,
they took away their
VH one of the vehicles.
They took away all their laptops,
cameras,
all that equipment,
stuck them in the car,
two go.
Do you have to be careful when you're
traveling that you have like a,
an obviously expensive laptop or camera,
something along those lines.
I think from the point of view of his,
you know,
they can,
they can take it away.
I'm going and it's happened a lot,
a lot of cases recently,
colleagues just being robbed.
Um,
I mean you get like an armed group and
the take away that basically the hold
them down,
take all their stuff.
So you don't know sort of going,
I know various colleagues,
photographers,
and if you're a freelance photographer
and you lose a good camera,
uh,
then,
then in there like,
you know,
some of the TV people would have,
they have less expensive
cameras and they used to,
I remember a few years ago,
a TV group,
uh,
interviewed some gang members are in
Honduras and they stole their camera.
And it was at that time it was like an
$80,000 camera and the TV network on a
say of what are the TV network apparently
was more pissed about losing the
camera.
It was about these guys,
you know,
again,
[inaudible] now having
guns pointed to them.
What is the attitude in Mexico?
Uh,
a special amongst people who are
studying the narco wars with all this,
uh,
build that wall stuff,
all this,
what's going on in America?
There's this,
this is very strange,
right?
Versus left polarization over here about
whether or not there should be a wall
between the United States and Mexico.
Sure.
I mean,
well,
I mean the thing Mexican's are
obviously very anti Trump in Mexico.
It's in a farm and I,
Trump is very unpopular from
the very beginning when he said,
I know they are rapists and murderers.
Yeah.
Someone's doing the raping.
How many?
He's kind of United.
You look at surveys,
the level's very low.
So is anybody like me?
Trump in Mexico?
I was there.
Like there's always contrarians.
I've seen numbers like,
you know,
people will say like 80% or something.
I think he's terrible.
Sent means they must be
at 20% somewhere else.
Don't.
I haven't met a Mexican who's been
like pro Trump and I never have.
I met a Salvadoran who
was pro Trump one time in,
in the heated guy had been
deported and he was like,
I know you'll get,
you know,
this guy,
Trump's going to turn out
to be a great president.
So,
so I see that.
But you know,
Mexico's very,
very anti Trump in terms of the wall.
I mean there's,
you know,
there's,
in terms of what
I intended,
the smugglers,
mom was talking to a smuggler in Nogales
about this and he was describing he,
he'd smile.
He was from Nogales,
from a neighborhood called Buenos Aires,
which is right on the border
with the United States.
He has no god,
Sonora,
Nogales,
Arizona.
So in August,
um,
so Noriega and Garth's Arizona.
And he was from the neighborhood
right on the border there.
And he described that he first took people
over the border of the United States
back in the 1980s when he was at school.
He's a high school.
And the reason was that that time was
just an old fence and there was a hole in
the fence.
They used to go through into United
States and go back into Mexico to send old
wire fence.
And the first time he took people through,
people would arrive from
southern Mexico saying,
how do we get to the US?
And he'd say,
Oh,
you know,
this way.
And they give them a tip.
He said the first time he
got the equivalent of about
50 cents was what you made
to take people to the
United States 50 cents.
Nowadays,
the cost of going into the u s is $5,000.
That's what you paid to go
legal in the United States.
5,000 bucks.
So we were saying,
wow,
look at that increase every time
that the u s puts more security,
it means it's more expensive.
When it's more expensive,
that means more money going to criminals,
which means there's not
an industry doing it.
So now the cartels make a big percentage
of that money of human smuggling into
the u s um,
by luck in terms of the wall,
I mean the,
uh,
wait,
when Trump first came in,
he had the line that
Mexico's going to pay for it.
Yeah.
And,
and then it was this
kind of line in a right.
The beginning,
he kinda,
he threatened Mexican president saying,
if you,
if you don't agree to pay for the wall
and why are you going to come and meet
me?
And then it was like,
wow,
he's really going to try to shake down
in Mexico for like billions of dollars.
Is He really going to try and do that?
Uh,
and that was kind of scary moment.
Then think from point of view of
Mexico when he first got to powers lie.
He's going to do that and then he's going
to deport 3 million and he's going to,
you know,
he's going to kill Nafta.
Yeah.
Actually those things
haven't really come to pass.
Actually,
if you look over the last couple of
years of Trump has some really hit Mexico
very hard.
So the concern was that he was going to
take money that should be allocated to
other ways.
It's going to help Mexico and he was
going to try to take that and use it to
build the wall.
I mean,
no one really knew when he first came in.
He's like,
oh,
Mexico's going to pay for this wall.
Right?
The Wall just got 10 foot higher.
I remember that.
Yeah.
It was light.
It was like in a,
how are you going to do that?
You're going,
are you going to start threatening
Mexican militarily and say,
give us money?
I mean,
it was kind of like,
uh,
like is it a,
is it a shakedown?
Good to shake down.
It was kind of,
it was kind of a crazy diplomatic
thing when he first got here.
So that was kind of scary for a moment
from the point of view of Mexico.
But I think after you look
at the last couple of years,
yes,
I'm really hit Mexico with and
now he wants to build the wall.
Now as he does it,
there's the big fasten in
terms of the spending here,
but if he wants to build it,
uh,
or Extendix,
there is warden sections of the border.
We're ready.
If he wants to extend it,
you know,
it won't stop.
A lot of the hard drugs.
I mean,
if you look at heroin,
cocaine,
crystal Meth,
high value drugs,
they normally go through
the ports of entry,
right?
So shipping.
Yeah,
I mean they go,
oh,
or through the,
through the ports of entry through Leica.
I mean you have a through in cost,
right?
Because trucks,
I mean,
you,
you go through,
if you look at the Laredo in Laredo,
Laredo,
one of the reasons that was a big fight
in the war started there in Mexico
because that's a very valuable territory.
There's something like 8,000 trucks
go over that border every day.
Now,
if you have 8,000 trucks,
how many of those can use search in a day?
And also the way they can
hide this stuff in trucks,
they can hide drugs in like a metal.
They can put them in,
in,
in some kind of metal container,
seal it up,
soldier it up,
put a bunch of,
so who doesn't smell?
So somebody has to say,
I'm going to open that with a blowtorch.
And as a searching after rip that
vehicle apart to find the drugs,
they were putting them inside wheels.
Yay.
Mass inside ties and stuff.
That's like the,
that's like,
there's song,
there's a,
is it,
that's one of the older tricks from the,
like the 70.
There's a song that is,
uh,
one of the first narco
corridos their drug ballots.
Um,
Eh,
it was called contraband and trend
treason for the 1970s and that was about
hiring,
uh,
hiding marijuana back in
the nine tires back then.
But yeah,
me now,
the trap cars now,
like super sophisticated,
they have some weird trap cars.
We have to do like a bunch
of stuff like open the door,
move some staff to actually to
actually open file the drugs.
Other slight,
some trick sort of door
has to be actively.
Yeah,
I would imagine if there's a will,
there's a way there's that much.
I mean,
I remember hearing that from,
it's not a reliable source,
but from the Sopranos there we're talking
about only 20% of all the shipping
containers or get brought
into America gets searched.
Yeah.
Well that's,
that's crazy.
Yeah.
Absolutely.
So,
so,
so to the,
the hard drugs and learned a
lot of time on through the,
the,
the ports of entry and,
and they have their data and other
classic trick they have is you get,
they allow some to get busted.
So you allow one guy to get
busted and they set somebody up.
So they're taking some drugs through,
they get,
they get busted or the f entities on them,
and then meanwhile more
drugs are going through.
And is this the United States border?
That's tests.
That's catching this guy.
Yeah.
So they're not getting,
they're not getting tested
in Mexico as they crossover,
right?
It's only in the United States border.
Yeah.
Some,
sometimes they might catch
him in Mexico sometimes,
but the majority is gonna
be the United States.
So the United States border patrol guys,
are they ever caught being corrupt?
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
There's been cases of us,
border patrol and customs
entry people who have been,
yeah.
Caught taking a bunch of money,
taking bribes,
allowing in our land certain cars
through the course Sandvik was through.
So yeah.
How does one fix this?
I mean,
if you had a magic wand,
you were going to wave it over
Mexico and fix this problem.
Like if you,
if somebody said you on,
you're a smart guy,
you've been in the
business for a long time,
we're going to let you
dictate how this takes place.
So I'd say,
yeah,
three things.
So like drug policy reform.
So we've got to talk about how
we deal with his drug situation.
So I mean like a mirror.
I mean,
I mean some of that is,
is here,
isn't it?
And you probably got a better
idea than me about how to,
why American,
what Americans takes so many drugs.
I mean I got from a drug
taking myself in the UK,
our guess.
So maybe it's not that different.
I think there's a lot of answers to that.
Uh,
the biggest one is entirely that most
people don't enjoy what they do and they
want an escape.
I think that's probably the biggest one.
The,
there's some ridiculous
number that was just a,
we're just who discussing the
number on the podcast have a,
how many people actually was it?
It was a Johann Hari,
wasn't it?
Yeah.
He was talking about the number of
people that actually enjoy their job.
67% people have in this country
don't like what they do or you know,
are just
sleepwalking through their life.
There's a another significant
percent that hate what they do.
And then there's a few leftover
that love what they do.
I mean it's a very small number of
people maybe like myself or maybe like
yourself that actually enjoy what they
do for a living and feel like they're
following their passion.
Most people were just working
a job and they fucking hate it.
And then when they get off work,
they want to get fucked up.
And a lot of these people,
you know,
they're,
they have psychological issues.
They're suffering from abuse,
childhood abuse.
They're trying to,
I mean there's been some significant
statistics about childhood abuse and how
many people from childhood abuse wind
up using and abusing drugs and becoming
addicted and even overdosing on drugs.
And it's ridiculously high.
It's about pain,
pain and suffering and trying to remove
that pain and suffering from your life.
And um,
you know,
people that don't know how to make healthy
choices and don't have friends that
are making healthy choices and don't
know what to do with their life.
That's a big,
big part of it.
There's another part of it that's because
it's illegal cause something about
things that are illegal that
are intoxicating and enticing.
You know,
when you look at the statistics in
Holland in particular where marijuana has
been,
you know,
you could buy it in coffee shops forever.
Not that many people smoke
marijuana in Holland.
It's a lot of,
uh,
marijuana tourism,
especially back in the day now that
America has legal marijuana almost
everywhere.
Not a lot of people are going to
Holland specifically to get fucked up.
But there was always the thing,
man,
when we were younger,
it was always a guy.
He's going to go to
Holland and go get high.
Like
I won't know.
No,
I used to go there,
one of the teenage well but never
there for some of that on a,
on a,
on a boat and arrived in Amsterdam,
uh,
back in those days.
Yeah.
It actually,
it made me,
made me swell small.
What you're saying is they're
about enjoying the job and is true.
I mean,
when he said that,
um,
I do love what I do and enjoy what I do.
So that's what Intel is one
of the size of that thing.
But,
uh,
but yeah,
so,
so I mean,
in terms of the issue of drugs,
we have to talk about this.
How can we stop American stop spending
that money or allowed that money if it's
going to be spent not to be going to a
black market and Andy stabilizing these
countries,
but also a lot of issues in,
in Mexico as well.
Uh,
like again,
that social work,
how do you change the reality?
And again,
so you know,
people who are abused
and suffer taking drugs,
but people who are abusing suffer
in Latin America becoming assassins.
Yes.
Because one of the weird things,
and on a,
on a moral level,
on a level of morality.
And I knew a lot of kids growing up who
sold drugs and there wasn't really an
amazing and moral thing to
think about in I sell drugs.
He was an easy step to take on a sim out,
sell some weed,
and then I'm gonna sell some speed and
sell some ecstasy and then layer on
heroin or would ever,
but for somebody to commit a murder,
that seems like a bigger,
a lot bigger deal.
How'd you get into,
how'd you crossed that line
to becoming a murderer?
How do they cross that line so
easily?
Well,
I think it goes back to that young
boy that you were talking about,
the butcher,
that family,
he was abandoned and angry and hurt.
So much pain and the suffering,
that's often the case.
They want other people to suffer when,
when you see people that are
doing terrible things to be,
but they're almost always suffering.
They're almost almost always wanting
other people to feel what they feel.
They're lashing out.
That's,
uh,
that,
that social work aspect that you're
discussing so critical and something that
we've discussed about this country
that how few people are putting,
I mean,
how,
and very few politicians,
very few people that are running this
country are putting efforts into try to
heal these communities that have suffered
from just years and years of systemic
racism,
years and years of just embedded poverty.
That's almost impossible to escape years
and years of crime and drugs and just
growing up in this community of despair,
this is what you were
talking about with Baltimore.
This is what we're talking about with
south side of Chicago and various cities
all over this country.
It just,
they don't get better,
man.
They date stay fucked up.
You know.
Um,
I had Michael Wood who is a police officer
from Baltimore and he was discussing
what it was like being in Baltimore as a
police officer and then looking at some
documents from the 1970s that detailed
the crime in the very same areas that he
was patrolling in and this the
same crime in the same areas.
And this sense of just
overwhelming futility.
Like there was nothing that
he was going to be able to do.
There's going to put a dent in this,
cause this was a lot of,
it was a product of in these areas in
Baltimore where there was law that you
were not allowed to sell homes to
black people in these certain areas.
So they kept these people
in these poor areas.
And even though they had this
desire to escape into the,
the more affluent or safer communities,
they weren't allowed to for a long time.
I mean,
there's so much of that
in this country that the,
you know,
the people that are in control,
but everybody just wants to get elected.
Everybody just wants to,
you know,
and then once they get elected,
then they're looking to get reelected.
So they spend a gigantic percentage
of their time campaigning.
No,
there's no universal effort on the part
of all the citizens of the country to
try to look at all these areas and say,
hey,
these,
this is us.
You know,
just because you don't live
in the south side of Chicago,
that those are human beings.
Those are just like you.
And I,
you could have been them.
They could have been you.
If they were you when you were them,
wouldn't you hope that you would help?
Wouldn't you hope that someone would
come in and try to fix this area?
Someone would try to Portman.
We pour so much money in the foreign
countries we pour so much money in is
subsidizing various industries
that a lot of people disagree with.
You know,
and there's,
I mean,
I'm not an economist.
I Dunno what economic sense
that on any of that stuff makes.
But I do know that money is allocated in
a lot of different ways and the idea is
that it's going to be
better for all of us.
Well,
it's not better for all of us to keep
these communities as fucked up as they are
right now.
And there's no effort,
nothing.
Very little done.
No movement,
no change,
no gigantic step,
no,
no 10 year plan to
eradicate gang violence.
No 10 year plan to radicating
illegal drug sales and murder.
So the,
this great social work,
they're awesome quest social
workers down there and said it.
Awesome heroes in these places.
And they're somebody I talked
to a lot based set up YDS,
[inaudible] Sandra who grew
up in the neighborhoods.
You're one of the first
people to introduce me to a
young gang members in this,
in this area.
Um,
she used to work in a factory,
they're going to social work and
now she's a psychologist and she,
yeah,
she,
I mean she's somebody who who really
will do the work and reach people and,
and like save lives.
Um,
and you know,
somebody,
you know,
basic stuff you really get
in the community and try
and reach and they have to
reach the kids when they're often 12,
11,
12 and you can often see
in these areas who are,
the kids are going to get into this,
who are going to be
recruited by the cartels,
who are going to get to gangs because
there's certain profiles in these people.
They haven't got their families.
I was talking to some guys in,
in also set up wireless
from the battery last Deca,
which is the,
one of the big gangs there started in the
u s actually among prisoners in spread
into Mexico and became almost
like a paramilitary group
in Mexico about how they
recruit people.
And then this guy was saying,
look,
you know,
we will see in our,
I can see from these young kids who's
going to be able to kill and you know
who's going to be a real
fight and who's not.
And if these people have gotten
parents who love them and so forth,
these guys aren't going to,
aren't going to,
they're not going to work for me.
I need,
I need someone who's like got hate,
who's calling to anger in them.
And I can,
I can do something with one of those.
It's kind of about the perverse
opposite of this stuff really.
But so if people don't have that families,
and this makes my guess,
think a bit more sympathize,
I guess as well too.
You know,
the,
the idea of how important family is,
handball and loving parents is,
you know,
whether you're together or separate,
leaner,
loving parents,
you know,
having that and uh,
uh,
but if you don't have that,
you know,
you need social work and new people
are going to offer something and try.
And now though there was a,
an interesting mayor of Midian,
good,
Andrea Guajardo and he had these ideas
of trying to change the reality of the
city and he said,
I'm going to build the most,
he was a mathematician.
So I've got to see us as
a mathematical problem,
this issue.
And I'm going to build the beautiful
building and the ugliest part of the city
and the worst part of the city to
make and force people who want to see.
We made a conservatory and put it in
there in the poorest neighborhood so that
people who want to be in this
conceptually have to travel to the poorest
neighborhood and go there and
try and change the reality.
Because if you see around you,
a horrible neighborhood at dusk street,
no light,
nothing working in a,
what do you turn into?
And if you see a nice
environment around you,
can you change people that way?
Wow.
How did it work?
It for a while,
it's hard to know exactly
because also there was a,
a truce between some of the
gangsters there as well for awhile.
Um,
was it related to the
construction of the conservatory?
I,
the theme I have met and have the
government was involved in the Theresa on
truth or not,
but there was for a time the murder rate
did drop quite dramatically in Midian.
Um,
I,
not that I have people have carried
on in a bit meti and has improved.
And Medi Medi in Columbia was the worst,
the most violent city in the world
back in the 1990s and it's not in an
industry,
you know,
people do like their city now in Midian.
Wow.
So it had some impact.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And the social workers,
I'm sure they have some
impact on individual people,
but I would imagine that the overwhelming
volume of children that are being
recruited,
that it's very hard to
put a real dent in it.
But I think in out quite has it had an
effect because when that was the most
violent city in the world around 2010,
2011 and now is this turf war
there between the Sinaloa cartel,
which is Chapo Guzman
against local widest cartel.
And there was a,
there was 9,000 killed in that
city over four years of that,
of that war.
It was crazy.
I was covering,
covering it then to just driving
around from scene to scene and be like,
yeah,
massacre here.
Masker they're just driving around,
Bang,
this things happening.
And afterwards there was a lot
of social work put into the city.
Um,
and Sandra described by lunch,
they said there's,
there's,
uh,
um,
I like a waterfall of,
of aid money coming in.
There was like us in a USA ID and stuff.
We stopped putting money into this and
other different groups and the murder
rate did really drop.
So,
and it hasn't gone back
up to that level since.
So I think it does have a real
effect when it's put as a policy.
Um,
and it does have an
effect on these things.
But also when you,
you talked a little while ago
about a magic wand on this,
I mean,
in making a police force that actually
protects the community or making a police
force that has some kind of effect.
I mean,
I grew up in England,
which is in a pretty safe place,
relatively in Nice and not
like police and you know,
hate the no beer anti police
would ever growing up.
Um,
and now I appreciate,
wow.
You know,
you have police who actually protect
community in some way and the same in the
United States.
I mean the United States,
the police do protect people to a large
extent compared to these countries.
And in obviously the tissues,
here is our issue of racism and
killing and violence and so forth.
But still,
I think a lot of the people who,
who believe that they know,
a lot of people believe they
have guns for self defense.
And I respect the right to
have constant for self defense.
But really in America you're generally
safe because the police are pretty hard
on clamping down.
But how do you create a police force which
really has the will to protect people
in a,
how do you have that,
you know,
uh,
with the,
the word and the passion and the
commitment to help people in Mexico.
That would be,
that'd be a dream.
The people that have dealt with police
officers that are corrupt have a very
difficult time hearing what
you're saying right there.
Those people would be angry
or what you're saying saying,
no,
the police officer's here are corrupt.
They are bad.
There is racism.
There are real problems.
Yeah.
Um,
and there is,
but I think there's also real
problem being a police officer,
period.
I think police officers have an insanely
difficult job and I think most of them
are dealing with PTSD.
I think there's a giant
percentage of them.
Like all over the world
and in America too,
that are constantly dealing with
violence and the threat of violence and
arresting criminals and being
shot at and people lying to them.
I just don't think,
I think most people are very ill
equipped to handle something like that.
I mean,
I agree there's,
there are definitely problems with
the police and there are problems.
I mean,
the police shootings are rare,
very real problems.
Uh,
please,
killing innocent people here is very real.
Uh,
and you've always got
to look for improvement.
And you know,
there's people,
families against suffering from that,
from that violence.
I don't want to belittle this.
No,
no,
you're not.
I know you're not,
I just have to sort of clarify because
I know so many people would be hearing
this and going,
yeah,
Mexico is terrible.
The United States,
there's,
I mean,
there's a ton of videos.
The real issue though is we're also
dealing with the sheer number of
interactions of police have with people
with the vast majority of them are fine.
Yeah.
The sound,
the,
the other thing,
like,
say that the crime of kidnapping
kidnappings are horrific.
Uh,
antisocial crime.
I'm a horrific crime and his choice lives.
Um,
there's one video,
a really video,
which really made me sick,
um,
which was given to a
family of a kid of buck,
a 14 year old kid who
was taken and they were,
they send this video to his family in
Mexico and they were beating this kid and
saying to this kid,
you know,
this is this,
you in the go center camera.
This is your fault bitch
to the mums is your fault.
Look how your kids getting beaten now
you're going to give me the money.
So I'll ask him for like,
uh,
was it $200,000 for time?
Um,
and those kinds of crimes and a kidnapping
doesn't happen in the United States
on a very big level because you've
got effective law enforcement.
So some,
I mean,
our house,
I was at one conference
and those are real nice,
real nice guy,
but there's people calling
for the abolition of the
police and they shouldn't be
a police force saying
you really want to live.
Like when no police,
you would only live with a dysfunctional
police when they can just kidnap your
kid
and like send a video to like that and
you've got no protection from that kind
of thing.
Right?
I mean,
there's definitely problems here,
but also you've got to see the,
the,
the other side of having completed
dysfunctional police force and what that
means.
There's just such a staggering difference
between the United States and Mexico
in that regard in regard to gang violence,
drug violence,
just overall murders and the
stories that we hear from over.
It's so different.
The fact that you could just
draw a little line in the dirt,
he crossed that line.
You're in hell.
And then you cross this line.
You're in Houston.
I mean,
that's fucking crazy.
Yeah.
I'm an a,
again,
I'm in,
I'll get criticized
sometimes from a metro,
sometimes Mesic Mexican government
sources or Mexican tourism sources.
And I like,
I'm covering this stuff so,
and I'm shining the worst.
Um,
and it can give it a story
picture sometime because you know,
when I tell a story of 49 decapitated
bodies with the hands and feet cut off,
people think,
wow,
you know,
as soon as you say this stuff,
when some guy describing cap there
and people with this kind of does,
um,
you know,
if not people outside.
And I don't say it was well as that
it is still is a great country.
I still,
you know,
a lot of the United States.
Um,
but I,
I probably love Mexico more.
And what do you love more
about Mexico besides the food?
Uh,
I'm an,
I would say generally
the atmosphere's good.
I just feel uh,
feel people are nice generally.
I think despite all of
this horrific violence,
do you think it's because they don't
have the same sort of a ruthless ambition
that people in the United States have?
I think there is a sense,
we were talking before about
why people are into drugs.
And one thing that occurred to me is
this kind of hyper competitiveness of
society.
And people can feel like failures.
Like if you feel like a fairly,
if you feel like,
I guess maybe social media affected
this as well because you see what people
have and you expect you to have more
and you feel you haven't lived up to it.
I think in Mexico people,
if you're broken the United States,
if when you come often maybe
feel like a personal failure,
how come you living in
America and you're broke,
right?
Um,
whereas in Mexico lots of
people are broke so he like,
you know,
it's like you don't feel that same
kind of personal failure with that.
When I'm there,
one thing that always strikes me is
how happy people seem and that I think
there's a certain stress level that a lot
of Americans put themselves into where
they're constantly pursuing
material possessions and
material wealth and success
and that oftentimes this leads to really
exacerbated stress levels and it's not,
it doesn't make you happy.
Like the whole idea of having
things in our mind is a,
someday if I buy this car,
I'll be happy.
If I live in this neighborhood,
And then,
so they work 12 hours a day to try to
achieve that dream and they're never
happy.
And they're always stressed out.
And even though the vast majority,
the United States,
I mean there's some insane number 34,
if you make one $35,000 a year,
you were in the top 1% of the world.
So there's a giant percentage of this
country that's in the top 1% of the world.
Yet the overall happiness level,
at least from what I've read,
is quite a bit below the people in Mexico.
Yay.
I mean,
yeah,
a lot of these things.
I mean,
how,
yeah,
how do you see you on happiness
will measure your own happiness,
will sense if of successful failure?
Uh,
so yeah,
so that's part of it.
I mean,
uh,
um,
getting the food is great.
The food is,
the food at the food is my
giant fan of Mexican food.
I love it.
There's a place down here that,
uh,
I take the guys here that
work here all the time.
It is as Mexican as you get.
No one speaks English there.
They have a Mexican soap operas playing
on the television and the food is just
sensational.
It's so good.
Yeah.
So,
um,
so,
so some of these things as well as that,
but,
but before you took him out this
border between Mexico and the u s yeah,
it's,
it's a huge,
um,
is that vast difference between
countries and cultures and I,
and the interaction,
another issue I guess is the
issue of guns going south.
And we talked about lot
other crops come up.
It was a god of firearms,
a lot of firearms.
Like that fast and furious deal.
Yeah.
Well the Eric Holder thing that went down
years ago where they sold it was some
sort of a sting and they sold guns and
those guns wind up being used to kill
Americans and even
American police officers,
ea show.
So that was,
so the ATF or gone off this and this,
I mean the number of guns knows
how many guns have gone down,
but there was one study that,
and it came to conclusion at about two
over 200,000 guns every year go from the
United States into Mexico.
So,
so that,
that isn't it.
That's an insane number.
200,000 guns.
And I interviewed a guy in prison in
set up wireless for gun trafficking,
and he would drive every weekend
from Mexico to the United States,
um,
by like 10 to 15,
mostly our fifteens
some other guns as well,
and drive them down into,
into Mexico.
And it's pretty easy to get into Mexico.
So you drive them in.
It's like,
it's,
uh,
a piece of Piss is very easy.
You basically,
most of the time you've got no control.
Now he would actually hide them in fridges
and in stoves and would pay an import
tax for the fridges and stoves.
Mm.
But,
but he was buying them and he said,
shit themselves.
And how did you buy the guns?
He said,
I would no idea to say what idea
did you showed to by your guns?
He said,
or nothing at all,
said no idea whatsoever.
So no,
no,
nothing at all.
So did buy them from gun shows,
see buy from gun shows.
But then what he would do was he
was used the private sale loophole,
which they're trying to close now.
So he would go in there.
And then I went to the
guns to a gun show in,
in Mesquite,
in the Greater Dallas area,
known as the gun show captain of America,
and went to Gunshow there ad asked people,
can you sell me guns in our,
I've done live here.
Can you tell me guns?
And first I said,
oh no,
you need to be tasteless.
And someone said,
Oh yeah,
sure.
Consider these guns.
And it was,
the reason to get out is
they say it's a private sale.
However,
some of them,
and I know some of the,
the,
the pro gun people get
angry talking about this,
but I saw this with my own eyes.
They've got a whole bunch of boxed up
EOF 15 rifles and they're sending them as
being private status.
So yeah,
private sale now he,
so he was just to simply buying
these guns and taking them down.
I saw right in front of me as well.
Somebody who,
who,
who said to the person,
I can't,
I can't buy it,
was looking for different gun and said,
no,
I can't buy it.
I don't have,
I can't use it to buy the gun.
Um,
and the person will,
you know,
still happy.
Like even the private
sale loophole if the,
if you,
in theory,
if you suspect the person is a criminal
or we use them for criminal purposes,
you shouldn't sell him the gun,
but they don't care.
And so one thing,
I mean,
you really want to,
people really want people who they could,
it could be ms 13 undocumented.
They can still walk in and buy
guns and some of these places.
Um,
but then,
yeah.
Um,
so that's,
that's a,
that's a big issue as well.
Yeah.
Those gun shows are pretty bizarre.
You're walking around with a bunch of
people just itching to shoot somebody.
They're just hoping somebody
breaks in their house.
I know a guy who keeps a gun
and his ankle at all times.
He keeps one in his back.
He's got a,
he's got a holster that
he carries with him.
Sometimes he carries a
knife is what I mean.
He's literally begging for
someone to fuck with them.
Mm.
I've got no problem with
the people who like,
uh,
and I,
I talked to a guy from the
Alaska machine gun association.
He had,
he has about 200 guns in his basement.
200 guns.
Wow.
And I'd have a problem with,
with,
uh,
with people with doing that,
but then there's still like,
how do you stop the Gun's
going to criminals the same,
the gun,
the criminals in Baltimore.
Um,
I also interviewed in Baltimore
or gun trafficker who,
who's taken guns into
the city of Baltimore.
The,
yeah,
the gun show loophole is very strange.
It's very strange.
That's allowed.
And this is coming from someone,
me personally who owns guns and I believe
in the second amendment and I just,
I don't think that the way to stop people
from doing illegal activities is to
make those activities illegal for
people who don't do anything illegal.
You know,
I think they're,
the real issue is the psychology behind
people that are willing to shoot people
in the first place and the deal with the
overall mentality of these human beings
and try to figure out what's
wrong with our society.
Curate at a base level,
at a,
at a human level,
that's what's really wrong.
It's not the inanimate object of a gun.
That's the problem is the human beings
that are willing to use these guns to
commit horrific acts.
That's what I think.
But when you have something
like drug cartels,
which or gangs
which exists,
and then you have this thing called a
gun show and then you have this gun show
loophole,
well boy you got a fucking
giant hole in your damn.
You know you got water
pouring right through,
right?
They're like,
how do you not fix that up?
If you are a person who
believes in second amendment,
you believe in legal
and responsible gun use,
you should be angry at that because that,
that represents a gigantic problem.
And that also represents a
threat to legal gun ownership.
Because if this keeps happening and
people keep getting outreach and more mass
shootings happen with illegally
acquired guns after a while,
you know there's,
there's,
it's going to come to some sort of a,
a real conflict with people.
Yeah.
I'm actually doing a new
book about gun trafficking.
Um,
so I'm really interested to hear about
his issues and on what the actual room
for compromise is all log.
We know someone like yourself who
believes in the second amendment.
How much room for compromise do you
think there is in on these issues?
I may like closing the gun show loophole.
The other thing,
like for example,
the issue of 50 cals.
Yeah.
Laugh 50 cows in Mexico,
the cartels,
cartels,
he's 50 cows.
They used them to set up ambushes.
They'll use it to hit a military vehicles,
please vehicles.
So they're,
they're the seller side of a mountain and
there are 50 cows and go back and bang
and I go right through it.
They're like baseball size bullets.
It's crazy now.
Massive.
Quite that big.
But they're big ass bullets now.
Yeah.
And I don't understand that a
lot of these myths completion,
military are corrupt as well.
But you know,
if you are an honest one or whatever,
you're going in a,
in a car and he's fucking
hit by one of those guns.
Your vehicle,
the now open up on you.
So is there any room there
do you think for like,
um,
clamp down on 50 cows?
I've never heard that
discussion that much.
I have a friend who was
one and see Anthony Kumina.
He's got a 50 caliber.
It's ridiculous.
It's crazy.
I mean the idea that you're
using that for self defense,
unless you're going to war
with Russia or you know,
fighting against some gang cartel gang,
that's a invading your city.
That seems that's a military weapon.
I mean it's the same
argument I think for uh,
having a,
a fighter jet with Hellfire missiles.
Do I think you should be able to own
a Cessna and fly a little prep playing
around?
Sure.
Okay.
Do I think you should
be able to own a jet?
Well,
I mean there are a lot of
rich folks with private jets.
Okay.
Do I think you should be able to own a
fighter jet that goes the speed of sound
or,
oh,
I mean it's just a faster jet,
right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Do you think you should be able to
own a fighter jet with 50 caliber guns
strapped to it?
Oh,
well what the fuck is that?
Are you starting a war?
Like what are you doing it?
This is like these levels
that things get to,
you know,
um,
that's this.
There's the argument against a t automatic
weapons or you can't use automatic,
like certain states have regulations
in terms of what you can and you know,
in California you can't
even have a silencer.
Um,
I don't know why because it's very
bad to have that loud bang of a gun.
It's terrible for your ears.
And if you're a hunter or,
or someone who likes to
shoot target practice
or something,
that's a terrible thing for your ears.
And there's a suppressor that get put on
the end of the barrel and will mitigate
that.
But for whatever reason,
I think mostly because of
films and public perception,
people think that those silencers are
only used by assassins or something like
that.
Are you using to kill people?
So do they,
they get it.
They convert the,
the semiautomatics from
the states in Mexico,
they convert the fully automatic yes
here too.
And then of course,
you know about bump stocks,
which makes it much more,
um,
free with the trigger.
I'm much,
much easier to fire rapidly rather.
So how do you feel about the issue?
You know,
one of the issues is of having a,
uh,
a database like the ATF or they're not
allowed to have a searchable database on,
on guns in the United States.
So they have like,
they have like paper files and stuff
they go through still and they can't have
like a digital database on guns.
That seems ridiculous,
doesn't it?
Yeah,
I mean you think they think I'm a bit,
I guess the,
these are the gun lobby.
See the idea of a guy in a registry as
being a step to taking away their guns
because um,
like once you start registering that
you can go then afterwards and say,
well we know where the
guns are or whatever,
but how do you feel thing there's
flexibility on that issue of like the gun.
I've liked having searchable databases.
I mean like with a car,
like you have a license plate and if
there's a hit and run you just type it in
and you know whose car it is within
seconds with gun tracing you can't,
you know,
you find a gun at a crime scene,
whatever.
You can't just trade
it in or put a button,
your Guy Bang.
That is,
they have to go through paper.
I have to go through a whole formal
trace and go through this kind of search.
She then there's flexibility
on that issue as well or,
or how do you feel about that yourself?
Well,
I've myself field,
there should be a traceable database.
I mean if it's just like a car and a
glad you brought up that analogy because
when you,
when you get a car,
you have to know how to drive a car.
You have to,
in order to have a license to drive a car,
you have to take a test,
you have to take a written test and you
have to take a physical driving test
with an instructor.
They have to see and think about how many
more people drive cars then own guns.
So it's possible to do this
with guns yet it's not done.
When I bought my first gun,
they're like,
here you go.
It's like what?
Like that's it.
Like yeah,
you're not a criminal.
Look,
we did a check check on you.
You're not a criminal.
Here's a gun.
And I bought a pistol about a 38 revolver.
That was my first gun.
And I went to the gun range and practice
with the gun and I read about how to do
it and I talked to an instructor about
safety and put goggles on and ear muffs
and you know,
make sure you're protected and how to
properly hold the gun while you shoot it
and all these different things.
But it's stunning to me that
you don't have to do that.
I mean,
you can own 150 guns and
know how to operate zero of
them and they're all yours.
You,
you don't even have to prove,
you know,
what the fuck then safety is.
You don't have to prove,
you know,
anything that's,
that's crazy.
But not me.
It's fun to shoot guns.
I'm not a,
since I've been doing research with
new pickup and shooting a few guns in
places,
I wa I went
over to Serbia and arrived
in Serbia on a hangover.
I'd see my friends in the UK and got
drunk with them and arrived in a hangover
and I'd met,
uh,
the contact dancer.
I wanted to go to a gun club and
he took me into a nuclear bunker.
And Find Ak 47 just came off the plane.
Wow.
Me.
And it was like,
wow.
They had a crazy,
I said,
whatever you want to fight at a crazy
amount of guns there so I can see it's,
it's,
it's fun to fire these things.
Do you think they actually
are good in self defense?
I mean,
do you,
do you actually think,
I mean,
I don't know.
It makes go.
I don't have guns.
Um,
I don't,
I wouldn't,
when I travel in the field,
um,
I won't go security.
Um,
they'd generally security is going to
be more of a hindrance because they're
attracted attention.
Yeah.
Tried to attention and you've got to go
basically what my hands up and send it.
This is it.
This is me.
It's what I'm doing.
And most of the situations there,
you've got to have a lot
of people with heavy guns.
You're not going to our gun.
These guys.
Yes.
In Central America was a
bit different in Honduras.
They were,
I was with guys with guns.
They're not out of choice,
uh,
of,
of choosing security because the,
the,
the journey's himself was Karen a gun.
And had friends carrying
guns and he was in,
he was carrying a mini UC
was driving his journey.
His friend of mine or Lean
Castro's name is Greg,
Greg Ernest.
He was driving around
and he had a mini UC,
um,
on,
on his lap as he was driving around to
crime scenes and running around doing
stuff.
Um,
but do you,
do you think guns are actually
effective for self defense?
I mean,
do you have guns for self
defense and believe in that?
I would simply just enjoy
the sport of shooting guns.
Well,
I hunt in,
uh,
one of the things I have used,
although I archery hunt.
Now most of the,
most of the hunts I go on when I,
when I go to these places to uh,
to bow hunt specifically.
Um,
but I have rifles for hunting.
I have hand guns for self defense in
it depends entirely on the situation.
That's like saying,
do you think cars are effective
to get you where you want to go?
Well,
they are effective.
If you drive carefully and you,
you know,
use the blinkers and look when
you change lanes and you know,
make sure you observe the speed limit
and all the different laws and are aware
and don't crash in anybody.
But if you're an asshole,
no,
they are not effective.
You're going to wind up
dying in a car accident.
You're going to flip your car
over in the side of the road.
Um,
if you're in a terrible situation,
it is better to have a gun then and not
have a gun if you know how to use it,
if someone's breaking into your house.
There has been,
there's countless stories of people
protecting their families from,
from bad guys when they have guns.
They,
these are real stories.
They do exist.
There are people that I've talked to,
they,
you mean you can find them.
There's countless stories.
There's also countless stories
of people leaving their guns,
uh,
unlocked and a child,
a child gets a hold of it and
kills himself accidentally.
There's,
there's stories of children
accidentally killing their mothers.
There's,
there's all those stories too.
So Ken,
a gun be effective in
self defense for sure.
That's why
the military used them.
That's why police officers use them.
That's why people train and they go to
the range and they take tactical courses
to learn how to use a
gun for self defense.
Absolutely.
A gun can be used for self defense.
It's the best thing for the
best tool for self defense.
Other than,
you know,
obviously living in a good neighborhood,
having a uh,
uh,
security alarm,
all these different steps.
A dog dogs are good,
especially at dogs as a trained dog.
But yeah,
guns absolutely can protect you.
If you're in a situation,
someone breaks in your house
and you shoot that person dead,
that's you.
You're safer then that person killing you.
That has happened.
But it's a decision that me,
this is a gross generalization.
That's an entirely dependent upon the
situation that you find yourself in.
But if you're not,
if you're not protected by,
uh,
if you,
if you don't understand how to use it,
if you're not trained,
if you don't,
if you don't have training to keep your
shit together when things go south.
Because when you're in a situation
and your life is in danger,
if you've never been in a high
pressure situation before,
how do you know you can keep it together
and even hit something you're aiming
at?
People have wild trigger panic and they
have a really hard time dealing with
life or death situations if they haven't
served in the military or have been
some very,
very high stress situations.
We have to learn how to control yourself
under extreme pressure conditions.
There's a lot,
there's a lot of factors there.
But I would say the
same thing as like you,
you would also say that with martial arts.
Like can you defend yourself
if you know martial arts?
Well,
depends on what you know.
I mean some martial arts
or fucking horseshit you,
you,
there's a lot of people out
there practicing nonsense.
And if someone who actually knew how
to fight just punched him in the face,
they would be doomed.
And then there's other people out there
that are experts that would be very calm
if someone tried to fight them and they
would know what to do and what not to
do.
And if the person wasn't armed,
they would be able to
easily dispatch them.
It really is dependent upon the situation,
how much effort you've put into it,
how much thought you've put into it.
And,
but there is a lot of people out there
that if you broke into their house,
you're making a huge mistake because
they are trained and prepared and ready
because they don't want to be a victim.
And it doesn't mean they're bad people.
And I think we,
we have a problem in this
country where we look at things.
They're very binary there.
One or zero there,
good or bad.
Guns are bad.
Guns are always bad.
I don't want to go on God.
God put bad guys.
Take your gun sometimes.
Sure.
Sometimes,
sometimes you kill the bad guy and
you protect your family though too.
That's real too.
Yeah,
no,
I have respect for people having,
having guns for self defense.
We were talking about that shooting.
I've been around a few shootouts
in Latin America and uh,
and over in Haiti.
And one thing about that from,
from a journalist point
of view and being around,
and I've been seeing a
lot of violence as well,
a lot people fighting.
Um,
even going back to England,
people having physical fights,
um,
or with knives and that kind of thing.
So one of the differences
I think with guns is,
and it's funny,
you can't see bullets is as I said,
it's such a,
it's a,
it's like a small thing,
but like you can't see the thing that's
hanging when you see a guy with a knife,
right?
It's like the guy's scary.
You can see,
you can imagine that
knife sticking into you,
but the gun is like you were seeing,
you know,
the object,
you can't see really that the polygamy in.
So one of the Times,
one of the Times I was in Haiti and I
went in to cover the earthquake in 2010,
which was,
you know,
real sad,
like crazy amount of debt day.
And we were covering the looting,
um,
afterwards and the police came and started
firing right into where people were
looting and was with a camera man.
And the police were fine,
Bang,
Bang and [inaudible] and it
drew in his same situation.
Not,
not right in that scene there,
but in another scene they
shot and killed somebody.
The police just firing at the looters and
all the Lucas started running when the
police or fire,
I note a foreign going with the,
how high were they firing
when they were firing,
you know,
Bang.
Finally split that.
And a camera man I was
with was just sat down.
He was like filming this.
And I think this is one of
the problems that wildlife,
cameraman get shot in these places.
You start feeling like
you're watching on TV.
Oh Wow.
Cause you feel like,
you know,
you're seeing the lasing loud is amazing.
Look or look at what I'm watching
and you're seeing this and this.
Let not saying run,
we've got to go like the fire.
And he was like,
was like,
it's like we got to get the shot.
We got a go.
Ah,
there's a,
there's another sad,
sad thing of a,
of a,
of a guy filming,
uh,
American journalist called
Bradley wrote and will,
uh,
in a rest in peace who was
killed in Mexico back in 2006.
And he was filming a shooting in state
of war Hakka and he filmed these guys
shooting and he fell and was
hit and it carried on filming.
Oh Wow.
He filmed his own death.
I mean,
you can literally see there.
Um,
yeah.
Sad has worked for news agency when that,
that day when he was,
when he was killed in,
yeah.
There's a lot of courageous
camera people and you know,
they get locked into that job
and it becomes normalized.
Almost like you were saying,
the people that live in
these war torn areas,
it becomes a normal way of
life to them and all their,
there are a lot of murders.
If you're there on a daily basis,
it seems like almost like a regular life.
A lot of these cameramen,
I mean they're courageous people.
You see these guys who go over to
war zones and film what's going on in
Afghanistan and you know,
and I've met some of these guys,
there's just,
it's a crazy way of life to just accept
the fact that you're an observer that
might be a victim and
you're capturing all this.
So people like me can get,
uh,
some semblance of a perception to what's
going on in that part of the world.
I went to the Philippines,
southern Philippines and saw the
fight against the Islamic state there,
uh,
in end of 2017 and it was interesting
seeing that compared to the violence I
cover normally in,
in Mexico.
So that was isis.
They took over to city morale.
We,
and it was an error.
They caught it.
It was,
it was interesting,
was more self contained.
They had,
uh,
an area called the main battle area,
the MBA thing,
may main battle area.
So in that area was isis
and the Philippine army just
done that at all the time.
Just like constant bang,
Bang,
Bang and planes going over and bombing.
But actually,
even when you're outside that main area,
even if you're,
you know,
we were just outside it and even if
you're like 600 meters or 600 meters from
it,
but it's,
you're not in the fighting,
the fighting is over there.
Whereas in something like Mexico,
South America locked on this fighting
is kind of happening everywhere.
There's no real control over Wayne
where the main battle area is.
But there,
they didn't really let
any journalists inside,
like deep into the main battle there and
didn't really let any journalists in,
was sitting outside and hearing just
constant ricochet of gunfire and,
but sometimes bullets
will come out of the area.
So there was an Australian guy and I
think he bent over to pick up some cookies
and a bullet hit him in the neck.
Um,
uh,
saw the x ray actually the bullet embedded
in the side of his neck and Nestle,
it takes taken out and he was so it
must've been at the end of its terminal
velocity.
Yeah.
So it must have been a far,
far,
far shot.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That went through something
else for it hit him.
Yeah.
So,
so he,
so yeah,
maybe it didn't go into fast
though that crazy though.
I didn't.
Yeah,
exactly.
So it was kind of a of beans.
Okay.
Yeah,
I think so.
Kay.
He was okay with it or that guy's lucky.
Yeah.
It's shot in the neck and you are okay.
So,
but,
um,
but yeah,
in terms of,
you know,
some of the people
who've really been in a,
um,
there was,
they would,
they had a,
one of the guys,
um,
one of the police special force guys
had a camera on his helmet and he went,
he showed me that footage
and he was right there.
Right inside they're going,
they're like really,
really close buildings fighting
with Islamic isis people.
And it was the same techniques I talked
to the general and he had a big chart
showing how the techniques of guerrilla
warfare had evolved from like Fallujah,
Aleppo,
Mosul,
and how this kind of weird new form
of guerrilla warfare they have of like
fighting house to house.
Um,
so there'll be besties is
suicidal kind of guerrilla war.
They rise up and there'll be like,
you know,
super close fighting really close.
It was,
and then when the bond they'd hired in
like in a basement and stuff and they,
they drill holes in the walls so they
can fire through and fight through.
And the footage he had,
he showed me the footage he
had from being like Ryan side,
close up,
like running literally in a room,
Bang,
taking these people out.
And it was like,
wow,
this just crazy.
I was trying to persuade the guy to
let me pull that footage out there.
You know,
it did look kind of crazy video game,
kind of cooler warfare.
So could've offered article
called call [inaudible].
Judy could,
could,
could have Judy.
Yeah.
Um,
I mean,
Mexico right now is almost like a war.
you can call it a drug war,
but because there's no,
it's not like an army versus army more.
We don't think about it that way.
But from,
in terms of the amount of violence that
goes on over there and the amount of
casualties it rivals,
anything that's going on
in the world right now.
Yeah.
So I'll be talking a lot about this over
the years and with some experts is a
good writer called Robert Bunker,
who's an external research if it a
Pentagon and he investigates this stuff.
There's a guy called John
Sullivan from here in California,
was a police officer who also did
a bunch of research and you know,
got like a doctorate in,
in,
in starting all this stuff as well.
Talk to them about their
ideas about what this means,
you know,
what is the,
uh,
um,
how can we define this
in terms of warfare,
you know,
how's it fit in?
And they directed me to one,
a book by an Israeli historian
called the transformation of war.
And this was written
back in the early 1990s,
and he basically predicted then you're
going to see a transformation in,
in,
in war and armed conflict
around the world.
And in our,
we have like nuclear weapons,
um,
but they're useless in these
situations and a nuclear weapons.
You can't use a nuclear weapon
to solve the problem in Mexico.
to deal with Islamic state,
uh,
in a,
these internally
insurgencies in countries.
So if you look at and Mexico,
so kind of weird,
hybrid hybrid says soap
with tween crime and war.
So I use the word crime Wallace
in some of these places,
say my Mexico,
El Salvador,
Guatemala,
Honduras,
where you have now,
maybe there are some situations
in Mexico where it be,
you know,
the Co,
there was a group who called the
helis go new generation cartel,
somebody,
a guy shot down and military
helicopter using an RPG seven.
Wow.
Uh,
and that killed eight soldiers and a
federal policeman in the helicopter.
There was one shoot out,
which involved 2000 federal
police and five hungered security.
It was like 500 cartel
hitmen had this crazy battle.
Mitchell can sometimes you actually get
acid starts to look more like a kind of
regular conflict.
But generally it's all,
you know what way more kind of hybrids.
There's kind of weird mix.
And Taj trying to get my head
around is for a long time,
for some years I was trying to
thinking or is this a civil war?
Should we look at it?
And then it becomes okay this.
And then it was,
we know Robert Bunker when heat,
when I talked to him one time and he said,
you know,
like this doesn't fit
into these theories in,
he's not quite war.
It's more than crime.
It's a weird hybrid in between,
um,
to kind of crime war.
And that's the way you
got to understand these,
these things.
But a lot of the conflicts
amount of world today,
these are spreading.
I mean,
you look up Somalia,
you look at Libya,
you look at a lot of these places,
it kind of weird mix instability.
And then this is what a lot
of refugees are fleeing from.
And,
uh,
I was down in,
um,
to Kuana,
Christmas I fired the migrant caravan
that came through Mexico Central
Americans,
you know,
which caused a big,
a big storm here that Trump kind
of here before the election.
What was that like or is that overblown?
Uh,
I think it was a big deal.
Um,
was it a publicity event?
Like,
cause that why they were doing it and
making it such a big deal and everybody's
walking towards the border.
Like there's a bit more than that.
I think there w uh,
there was,
um,
there,
this caravan,
it started a few years ago and they
started off in Mexico for security.
Um,
there was an issue back a few years ago
where the cartels would kidnap migrants
en masse.
They will just get loads of migrants
and you think these people are poor,
how can they make money from them?
But they'd get them,
put them in camps and they know they
have family in the United States.
So they say,
okay,
we've got 50 people in the camp.
We want $5,000 off each
one of you off your family.
Like give us number,
we're going to call your family.
Okay,
send us the money.
That and then sometimes they'd agree on,
okay,
2000 you know like,
but so sounds like you know you're
making money out of poor people,
but you do it on mass.
You do it 10,000 people and you get
a couple of thousand dollars each.
That's like $20,000 200 to 200 minutes.
I told her $1 million,
so they started doing caravans for
strength to avoid these mass kidnappings.
What was different about
the latest caravan?
The actually became,
became a caravan crossing borders.
It used to be going through
parts of Mexico together.
Then they started crossing borders.
Now the caravan began in October,
around October 12th and there was a call
for them to meet and my friend all lean
again though the journey's
done in Honduras.
He was down there filming with his TV
crew putting on TV or they're down here,
they're going on this caravan.
It's only when boom and like Lowe's,
people saw it on TV and they're like,
I'm going,
I'm leaving,
I'm leaving now.
The desperation was so heavy in a,
Honduras isn't a real
meltdown kind of stage.
Honduras is bad Venezuela's worse,
but Honduras might be like number two,
far,
you know,
real meltdown cases in
Latin America right now.
So people were like,
no,
talk to some of these people.
They would say that I saw on TV and I was,
that's it.
I'm going to decided right away,
I'm going to get my bag,
I'm going to go.
So they arrived at the,
when they went through and got
a mile into quite a miler in,
they became big like 7,000 people,
um,
arrive at the,
at the border with Mexico and you know,
first of all they try to,
they,
there was a,
a push and shove on the board and tear
gas was fired and they went down and
cross the river in some of them
walking across with a rope.
Some of them go across on tires.
It was kind of crazy scene in the scene.
Now there was squatted half the
bridge and the now kindness.
It was kind of kind of a big deal.
I know the idea of calling them
an invading army and so forth was,
was,
was obviously overblown,
but like I think it
was significant scenes,
quite storic scenes that
were happening down there.
And what was the overall goal to
make it through to the United States?
Yeah,
I'm in a different people
at different ideas.
It was kind of on his weird things,
you know,
like it was girly nights,
days.
Now some people had no idea where
they will go and had no real plan.
Some people [inaudible] had very clear,
um,
cases of being like I'm a refugee.
Um,
in our understanding a bit about
refugee legislation and not fleeing very
specific cases where they've
been targeted by gangs,
working with corrupt police
who want to kill them,
who have like hacked them and they've
run and like I want to seek refuge in the
United States or in Mexico,
someone them seeking refuge in Mexico,
which is not the safest place to see each.
I like,
there's been cases of people who have
one camera man or know who fed Honduras
and then was killed in Mexico.
Has there ever been any discussion of the
United States military intervening and
trying to do something about the cartels?
So there's been like a us,
um,
you know,
some US forces like us marshals,
um,
sometimes they're like,
you didn't,
Mexico's very proud of its constitution
and very proud of its sovereignty and
doesn't want us force acting in Mexico.
And I think the,
the,
the kind of idea really of,
of US military military's
pretty out there.
How is pretty,
uh,
you know,
like it wouldn't help if he's be
bogged down into more problems and,
and there'd be nap time
in Mexico Ford App,
but there have been some cases of us
doing some kind of activity in Mexico.
Like for example,
when they went off to chapel was man,
when they got him and
there's a big shootout.
No,
they've gotten the first time
I said without shots fired and,
and then he went to prison.
He escaped that one escape from her.
He says keep more than once.
Right.
And escaped twice.
Yeah.
Did he get helicoptered out once?
Nothing.
I'd to have been a happy
and how he called down,
which is crazy.
He had the one tunnel escape
with the electric bike,
which was crazy.
Yeah.
The,
when he went to the John
and went to the bathroom,
we just step behind
the door and he's gone.
That was insane.
It was really weird when I
went to New York right now,
seeing him in the court in New York,
like seeing him in the flesh after
all these years covering this stuff.
And I saw him and it was like,
Oh,
I've been to his village before.
I talked to his mother,
had stayed the night with
his cousin in his village.
Wow.
Up in the mountains.
Uh,
you know,
seen.
What's it like up there?
It's um,
an eye,
quite a rugged mountains as
Sierra Mar that is like a,
you go in a car up and uh,
unlike,
we are now in a four by
four serious off road,
up and down.
And
there's people we know wandering around.
They're fully armed guys like ski mask,
Hmong guy like camouflage gear,
cammo gear key Moscot AK 47,
just like,
or not quad bikes,
just driving around the area.
Wow.
And we went up there with a
colleague and a photographer,
have soy for Time magazine.
And we went up there and drove it to
the village and I bought a bottle of
whiskey thinking to,
to kind of offer to the,
to the family member to say,
Oh,
you know,
here's a,
here's a bottle of whiskey to,
and when we arrived there and uh,
and he said we could stay at his house.
And I bought a bottle of whiskey
so they know his and he said,
we don't drink in this house,
we're Christians
if we take drink.
And this is nice guy.
And he was like evangelical
Christian wow cousin.
And he was,
we'd sit there talking and he'd be like,
quoting the Bible well and come and stuff.
And he knows like the exams
are not understanding.
And there's a church,
it's an evangelical church right there,
which is supposedly built by chapel,
which is mother goes to
right in front of her house.
And we sat through a three
hour evangelical service.
I'm sitting there with,
you know,
Chapos mum there and all his family
members were sitting there and the cars.
And even said,
oh,
we've got some friends here,
cause he got,
he was,
he was basically what he said,
like,
he stay with me,
you know,
you're my responsibility
if something happens,
you know,
I'm gonna have to pay for this.
So we're like,
yeah,
we're not going to behave ourselves in,
in the village.
And he said to the chair,
to them,
we want to have also have what,
we have somebody from England here and
somebody from the u s and come out in
this,
in this church ceremony.
So yeah,
yeah.
Really,
really bizarre scenes up there.
And there was so bizarre to,
but did you talk to them about the
contradiction of being an evangelical
Christian,
being involved in essentially a mass
murder and drug running operation?
So,
so the cousin is supposedly,
and he was like a cattle
ranch and now I don't exactly,
you know,
obviously he's,
he calls,
um,
you know,
he,
I didn't know how much he might
have been involved in the past,
but his,
his,
he says he's,
he's,
he's a farmer there and the mother,
um,
Chapos mother who's 88 or was 88,
they're now,
it's like 89 90 now.
Um,
you know,
she talks about her son
with kind of pride it,
I did it and I didn't push too hard and
there was a gunman around and stuff.
I didn't like [inaudible].
Um,
but,
uh,
but yeah,
I mean they,
this is,
this is their way of life.
I mean these,
these are,
so seeing him in the court,
um,
was kind of bizarre seeing,
you know,
seeing him right there.
And in New York,
in Brooklyn,
you know,
right there in Brooklyn
and they bought it.
All of these crazy characters
is p as a cooperating witnesses.
They brought in 14 cooperating witnesses.
I'm on a bunch of other gangs.
How does they protect those people?
Yeah,
I mean heavily,
heavily protected.
I mean,
I think,
I think it was ethically very questionable
why they bought a lot of those people
in.
Um,
they were,
they brought in one guy whose nickname
is Jupiter Petta who confessed himself as
many as 150 killings and
maybe did a lot more,
uh,
and,
and he makes a deal,
likely makes a deal to cooperate
against their chapters.
So you get into a kind
of weird intrigued there,
um,
about what the government was doing.
This whole case is,
there's a history in this country
with the prosecuting the mob,
John Guardian,
Sammy the bull Gravano who so admitted
murderer and talked about the murders
that he committed and still they
allowed him to get free day one.
His want to hit John got his lawyer
was one of the lawyers for our chapel.
Of course.
Yeah.
And then they head out to the,
that they got something to
do with these lawyers there.
It was a crazy kind of show.
Yeah.
It was weird.
It was like in a New York and this
show they were putting on there.
Um,
it,
I felt kind of disconnect with the
things I've been seeing over the last few
years.
And it didn't really,
why was it in New York?
The United they indicted him and a bunch
of places and I think they chose New
York for the reason they
wanted more of a show.
Wow.
I think,
I think they,
and they,
they,
they bought in a more than 50 witnesses,
you know,
three and a half,
three months of Crile.
Uh,
what was his defense?
So they originally tried
a bit of a defense of,
they wanted to go back to fence of how
there's a kind of government conspiracy,
um,
of like showing things like fast and
furious that you mentioned like saying,
oh,
how come the government's
trafficking guns,
two cartels and one of the witnesses
had before one of the witnesses against
him,
it before use this weird defense
called public authority saying he had
permission from the United States
government to traffic drugs are basically
saying there's a kind of conspiracy
involving in Mexican government's tardy,
corrupt and working with cartels.
The U s government is corrupt and
working cartels and having very specific
agencies and El Chapo was kind of a full
guy that they're putting this blame on
now.
That didn't really the gut,
the u s prosecutors shut that down.
And the judge,
they just said,
you can't talk about this stuff.
You can't say that.
So I went fast and furious,
came up,
they said,
no,
you can't talk about it.
You can't talk.
You can't,
who couldn't talk about it in a court?
Well that's ethically ambiguous,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
That's a real thing that happened.
Yeah.
So there was,
you know,
we can't talk about it as you add to that.
And then the defense tried a bit,
well they had audios of
El Chapo and they said,
Oh,
do you know how you noticed him?
And is he really the main
guy in the law cartel now?
There is as well.
Um,
very possibly he's not the top guy in,
in Arcata.
They might well be another guy called
miles and bother who's the number one?
And he might be more of
an emblematic figure,
but for some reason El Chapo became
the most famous in the world.
And so this other guy's,
he's still free.
Yeah,
What is his name again?
Myo.
Zambada.
Uh,
and where's he?
I knew somewhere in mountains.
Mezcal throws in the mountains often many.
What are these,
these weird things you'd think?
Like if you're a drug lord and
you've got all of the money,
you know,
you've got millions,
billions,
they say,
let's say hundreds and millions.
I think they exaggerate how much money
some of these guys have individually.
But then you could go
anywhere in the world.
Do you think you could go somewhere out?
But these guys tend to be
in their places that they,
they're,
they're people.
Like some of these people are
people who are very educated.
I mean a chopper who's,
as a kid,
he was carrying sacks full of oranges to
sell almost an education and they start
handling hundreds of billions of dollars
that do dealing with a billion dollar
international business and they've got
the capacity to understand and deal with
that.
But at the same time,
they still really hyper
local in some ways.
They're still like people who,
they understand their world,
they understand it from their
environment to control them,
become masters of their environment,
um,
to become kind of powerful in,
in that place,
who in that place.
But you know,
they couldn't,
you know,
the idea of them go into like sitting in
Italy in a cafe and kind of running it
from there and they don't,
it's kind of beyond that would have
to be there near the business because
otherwise someone would just take it over,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So that's how many have to run
that thing with an iron first.
Yeah.
I mean,
you could,
you could think though,
or maybe like,
yeah,
I guess so.
He really get your Christian cousin,
you won't rip you off.
Yeah.
But how am I also,
how much money do you need to make?
Right?
Taking you get out.
Maybe when it,
again with corruption,
I mean there's the issue of like
a lot of police in Mexico poor,
so that's why they take deals.
But there's uh,
an ex governor called Thomas,
he Addington who I met a few years ago
when he was governor of Tamaulipas state
and uh,
again,
he was not only taking money from drug
traffickers after he left being governor,
he got into drug trafficking
himself and he's like,
you think,
well once you made couple of million,
right,
do you need to make an art 10 million?
But then again,
governor,
the same with,
I don't understand the
business we've been,
this is what does it,
what's the incentive?
Why did they think they always
want to make more money?
I don't know.
I mean we were talking about that recently
with Jeff Bezos when we found out he
has $150 billion.
Like when do you just say we're good,
we're good.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't know.
I think it becomes,
it's a game more than it is anything else.
Like there might as well be
playing Parcheesi or monopoly
or what they're trying
to win.
You know,
they're trying to constantly win.
And also you have an obligation
because you're a CEO of this company,
so you,
you're running this enormous business
that's earning money for all these other
people as well.
It's all very complicated though.
That has to do with a lot
of psychological where
people can't put things into perspective
and they get caught up in the race.
Hmm.
Yeah.
I guess,
yeah,
maybe drug traffickers are thinking that
same thing somebody does when they're
making.
And then also that like,
like,
you know,
people have explained to
me involved in this world,
they make a lot of money,
but they spend a lot of money.
While these numbers are wrong,
knock with chopper.
They said,
um,
his worth $14 billion.
That's what the US government said.
In that case he's worth 14 billion.
But then he's,
you know,
peerless bay to me,
you,
you know,
14 billion is when you
take the value of drugs.
You'll send Hee Hee.
He trafficked and you're
adding the opera singers,
$14 billion worth,
but really all the time
you're paying back suppliers,
you're paying people off
your own money and you know,
and you know you're
buying hippos and chats,
cold covered rolls Royces.
Yeah.
There's some of that.
I think some of that was,
might have been exaggerated with him.
He had a lot of kind of more
like middle class houses.
Oh yeah.
I went to one of the last,
the last hideout he was caught and
it was more like a middle class.
It's just a normal house in a house,
but he'd have a lot of those.
What the fuck happened with Sean Penn?
Yeah.
Why was Sean Penn up there talking to him?
That was so strange.
Yeah.
The photograph was Sean Penn and shaking
hands with them and then Conor McGregor
wore that same t shirt and it took
that same pose on when he was,
when he was a got of fight.
Eddie Alvarez,
I believe it was.
Yeah.
What was that about,
like why was Sean Penn visiting him?
Yeah.
Bizarre moment.
I mean you have a,
an actor who's played
gangsters areas right there.
Yeah.
I'm an actor who's played gangsters
with a gangster who they're having,
you know,
movies made by him.
And there was a woman that Sean
Penn knew that hooked us all up.
But I'm just gonna steal the,
she's a famous Mexican actress.
Yeah.
So,
so the story,
the whole story started there.
She is.
Yeah,
I've got them all power on
around hey me with a murder.
Yes.
I nice to be married to Madonna.
So the story started,
so Kate,
the Castillo who you see there,
she was an actress in a TV
series about drug traffickers,
which have now become a
huge deal in Latin America.
They called out like telenovelas
means like soap operas kind of thing,
series TV series and the whole badge
them made about drug traffickers,
which are really popular.
And she was in one
called La Reina del Sur,
the Queen of the south.
And in that she played this
drug trafficker and afterwards
in some kind of weird
moment afterwards,
I think she was like really
into her role and stuff.
She came out with this message,
she wrote saying,
I'm in a Mexico is in such a disease,
such tragic situation in Mexico.
Um,
you know,
why don't they come in a drug
traffickers common like um,
traffic with love.
I trust you more than I do the government.
And these are kind of sentiments
that some people have,
but you know,
it was kind of a strange thing kind
of bit of an out there thing for,
for a TV star to say.
And then Chapo,
El Chapo apparently became kind of
enamel with her seeing her on TV and they
started this kind of communication.
Now Sean Penn then got involved
in this and was like Ah,
in,
I'm going to go there as well
and we can talk about the idea,
but the end of the tens of the meeting
was as well talking about making a movie
or TV series of his story and our
chapel giving the rights to Kate.
The Castillo in Sean Penn was
kind of involved in this summer.
Now Sean Penn is a bit of discussion
that now that Sean Penn and Kate del
Castillo fell out over this.
They have different versions
of what happened there.
But you know,
Sean Penn decided to go and write this
story for rolling stone about how to
experience,
yeah.
So they went then and his meeting was
arranged and they went up to the mountains
and when that photo was taken and I,
they eat at that point that he didn't
actually give an interview to Sean Penn,
but they had a dinner and had a
meeting up in the mountains and,
and then left.
And then there were meant to afterwards,
there was then a big
attempt to hit chapel,
but he escaped.
So that's when some people say that the
Mexican government had followed them in.
I use their,
their trace or try and get to a chapel,
but he did escape.
He almost got caught close to there
quite soon after as by escaped.
That's makes sense.
I mean,
how else would Sean Penn
be able to slide through?
Is a famous actor.
I bet he doesn't even speak Spanish.
Yeah.
That housing daggy does.
I mean,
I don't know if,
so if he was followed.
I'm not saying that he was,
um,
in any case,
in any way deliberately.
No,
I leading them there,
but it's something that I
think about all the time.
I think about,
okay,
if I'm going to meet criminals,
um,
am I being followed?
Um,
and am I going to lead,
you know,
what's my connection with Laura
force much conviction with criminals.
It's a very difficult thing that I've
been bantering and thinking about for lot
of years.
So anyway,
the Chapo escapes,
um,
and then said he couldn't meet up
again for the interview because he was,
it was too hot for him.
So they made this video interview
where he was sent some questions and he
videoed himself answering the questions,
which is kind of interesting.
It was the first kind of
statement he made and he said,
I know various things.
I've been doing it since I was 15.
It didn't really give much away.
And then he was caught and when
he was caught they were like,
we've got to move to stories.
And then the story came out large bang
after he was caught in early 2016 so it
had to have some sort of an
impact and then catching them.
I must've,
I mean,
it's possible.
Uh,
makes sense.
It's possible.
I mean,
chopper thing was pretty,
you know,
he'd already been caught before he
was caught in 2014 was imprisoned,
escaped in 2015 through that tunnel and
then was caught again in 2016 so yeah,
me maybe it had an impact on United on
that when they were looking for them.
Yeah.
They were looking for him and he seemed,
he seemed to have lost a lot of
his protection in a he before.
And I go back a few years.
I know he had enormous protection
in and there's mountains.
I mean,
in a village you see
there's a house above,
like there's a,
there's kind of a main clearing
where his mother's compound is in,
so pretty basic still that
village then are up from there.
You see a,
um,
a house on a hill and
apparent that as well.
Chapter for long time.
He said,
don't just stay in that house.
Um,
in,
uh,
in one is in the run.
In the past,
he had so much protection.
Anytime the military will
come close at the mountain,
you've got hundreds of people in radio
saying that if they were coming up,
I'd get clear,
man,
what a crazy world you study.
Really.
It's,
uh,
it's amazing.
I really appreciate your coming
here and talking to me about this.
And,
uh,
this book is El Narco.
Do you have more books are available?
Yeah,
she'll say my first book sell narco.
My second book is a gangster warlords,
uh,
which also has,
um,
stuff on their ms 13
on the gangs in Brazil,
the gas in Jamaica as well as Mexico.
And I'm working on my third book now.
And the third book is about,
about gun trafficking.
Hmm.
Well,
listen,
man,
I really appreciate
your time and that you,
you've lived a very,
very fascinating life.
Stay safe out there,
man.
Great to be here.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it,
man.
Thanks man.
Thank you very much.
Wow.